[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to a very special episode
of the trash taste podcast i'm with the
boys
all suited up gamer gamer and pro gamer
right normally we are the boys but today
we are the men the men no no the
gentleman the gentleman exactly
i do want to say joe your jojo suit
looks fantastic well i want to say
connor you're jojo
you know you tried it's a suit but it's
not a jojo suit gone i'm a little
disappointed i did actually buy a jojo
suit but it came in
and i thought l size would be big enough
here but i forget that japanese sizes
are like one size smaller
than the rest of the world size is
basically just the kids size everywhere
you're wearing the bucharati suit all
you just i'm wearing the butcher
full set up you're wearing the kira suit
is this is this is this out yet
oh yeah it is how it is out now you can
buy it now and uh yeah it's a three
piece so you got this i mean i would
show it all off but
unfortunately our debut with the suits
on the trash taste podcast is not the
jojo episode
no it's not but uh we've got we've got
something even better we've got uh the
annual i guess it's gonna be the first
annual trash taste award war
everybody everyone and everyone
congratulations congratulations i think
we've had enough
cringe-worthy moments i'd say yeah
we've had a lot of moments in the last
year that's uh i guess i guess this is
like literally the [ __ ] obama meme
where we just like congratulate
ourselves
why do i not do this on my main channel
but uh yeah so to address the elephant
in the room uh
this will technically be the one year
anniversary yeah trash taste because
this is for a whole year
episode 50 episode 50. hopefully
and i mean like it's not episode 52
because we've had two specials uh which
is
frankly amazing that we could have
fitted already two specials in here
right the current world climate i'm just
more shocked that
we've been doing this for a year now god
it feels like it's gone very fast
it feels like it's been like two months
and it's also felt like it's been 10
years at the same time you know what as
well i i rewatched a little bit of the
first trash taste episode as well oh
yeah and i was like wow it's so
different
really so different are we all still
like awkward as [ __ ] in that yeah a
little bit and we're all hurry
[Applause]
oh as well yeah i suppose if it's
actually
i don't know if the counter is right
because we swapped every episode but
the counter isn't correct but we are
sitting in the scene coincidentally
we're all in the same
complete coincidence yeah god i want i
want to see a comparison of this episode
yeah the first episode like side by side
yeah that'd be crazy but yeah so uh we
asked you guys over on the subreddit
and also uh was it on twitter as well
yesterday yeah we're on twitter as well
we asked you guys around our social
medias uh to give us some awards to give
to
ourselves especially that's the only way
to describe it really
we're just like hey we're just like hey
we got a bunch of categories for a bunch
of different awards and
it's all voted by you guys the trash
taste viewer so
right now us three have no idea we don't
know who's gonna win
and by the way shout out to our intern
ashley
who helped sort out these awards and uh
these
beautiful beautiful envelopes which we
are going to be opening yeah it's the
awesome
this is this is as legit of an awards
show as well this is the first time
we've given him a job but that's not get
us coffee
so he really pulled through with us for
that
i shall open the wine carry on talking
please open the wine and a shout out to
ashley as well for actually dressing up
even though yeah yeah even though he's
not technically going to come out
do you want to join johnny do you want
to come on camera quickly ashley come on
give him
give him yourself give yourself look at
that okay look at look at that look at
look we didn't even ask him to wear a
suit he just walked up with a suit
because he's a professional boy yeah and
then melin shows up with
the tackiest
with just your box standard t-shirt and
we're like melon come on baby so the
trash taste award yeah
we were like mainly this is the trash
taste award so you know what to do right
we might get more viewership than the
oscars it's
too nice it's entirely possible i mean
that's not surprising to be honest
but uh yeah so i don't know i guess
before we start and while connor's
opening this i guess we can do like a
quick little reflection of
the year oh by the way it's called award
woo oh yeah yeah
because in the original reddit post um
connor misspelled awards yes and i guess
we'll
we're just rolling with now it's so the
trash tastes war dudes not the wards
it's literally like the same root as how
like the word kek was invented like
it's just a missed type that's okay yeah
i didn't know that oh no no it was uh
how pone was invented
oh yeah that's true because own because
the o and the p is right next to each
other and then it became pwned
yeah so there you go new meme yeah so
how many categories do we have
today 25 i believe if i recall correctly
25
25 categories with i think over 24
000 votes how many votes did we get
for the survey ashley if you want to put
that up
there it is the wine is open there you
go all right
while we're waiting let's uh pour some
wine where did you wait this is a
hokkaido wine right it is hokkaido wine
yeah
is that the one you bought yeah this was
like five months ago yeah right
we never drank for some reason yeah i
think it was buried in the fridge even
though i don't think we should probably
just have we have like a bunch of
alcohol that's just buried in the fridge
we have a lot of alcohol on stand
by for a moment just like this finally
the wine glasses
fitting with the the outfits that are
exactly right look at us
look at us look at us if only i could
recreate my
hair
cheers boys cheers successful yet yeah
absolutely awesome yeah i have the
numbers you have the number
what are the numbers what is it 24 210
24 210 votes yeah so 24
210 of you voted for what we are going
to present
so if you have if there's any salt you
can just blame yourself
and if you didn't vote well you kind of
missed out yeah exactly
next year yeah exactly next year yeah as
i said this is probably i said first
annual because
hopefully as the years go by we can kind
of keep doing this every year we can
make it like a yearly tradition if you
guys enjoyed it of course look at a
chill little episode where we just uh
kind of
reflect yeah yeah we look back yeah
because not a filler episode it is
the trash tastes like i'm not a filler
i've been looking forward to this
episode because
like i've completely forgotten so many
moments that happened throughout the
year until we went through like the
nominations that you sent and i was just
like
oh yeah that did happen didn't it well
because if you know
simple maths right like what it's a
hundred
hundred hours of us talking for the past
year that's 100 hours of content over
the year if not including the it's like
100 specials oh it's like 120
uh 120 minutes per episode so right i
don't really want to know like two hours
two hours in episodes like 100 hours
right so which is a lot of talking
it's like so no wonder we've forgotten
so i mean to be honest like every time a
new episode goes up
i genuinely don't remember i don't i
don't remember the [ __ ] i talked about i
don't know how
like you guys know what we talked about
more than we do most of the time you
guys know the law better than we do
definitely i'm excited we jump in to see
what uh what our categories are
sure sure let's let's let's go towards
our category so uh we asked you guys
what categories you'd like to see
and based off that we chose these 25.
there's quite a lot here as you can see
on the screen yeah so
just to read them off quickly so we got
best intro uh hot take of the year best
out of context clip screen grab of the
year most degenerative moment
saltiest moment most monkey moment i
love that best story
biggest clown biggest chad best nickname
uh best complaining about american
moment because
you know of course that's what this is
all about of course we got the best meme
best tangent best trash test special
moment best drip
lazy strip which is i thought i'd never
say that in my life
best trash taste animated best rant
catchphrase of the year
guest of the year best argument best
trash taste special
uh best trash tasting moment and the
best
episode overall so lots to cover today
i'm very excited to see what the gamers
out there shows yeah right
because there's some of them where i
feel like i think i know what's going to
win
yeah there are some of them i'm like i
genuinely have no idea no i think some
of them were pretty close as well yeah
because a lot of the nominations i guess
like were differing on how we felt about
it right yeah
for one category you know there would
have been one nomination where i
personally was like
yeah that's gonna win and then you guys
are like no no it's this one right so
yeah we don't know and there were some
categories where i thought i knew the
winner of that nomination and then
the actual nominations came in i'm just
like oh i completely forgot about this
yeah oh this is getting really hard now
exactly exactly so
all we know is the actual nominations
well we don't know
at all who the winners are going to be
who the winners are yeah so i guess uh
without further ado let's see we've got
a lot to get through today let's just
let's just jump right in let's start off
with the first category that of course
uh being the best intro best intro just
the tip we asked ashley to put
uh these like tag lines for each of the
ones as well which i'm seeing for the
first time
i didn't realize we asked him to do that
that's the first that's the first i've
heard about this what is
the best intro nominations you're
probably wondering well here they are
uh let's find out oh oh god
no actually you spoiled the winner
all right so the first one is the salty
salmon slices from episode four i don't
remember this one this is the first
one that i did which is different okay
okay let's listen to this one
what's up you salty salmon slices
welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste podcast
i'm sorry you know how old it is when
you see how long my hair is
in that oh yeah because this was before
you got the haircut before i got the
hair
i remember you didn't did you i don't
think you told us that you're just going
to do a random introduction i think
that's how it started yeah
i was like these dumb intros begin from
this point yeah exactly
i mean i think that's where they started
yeah yeah yeah because most of these are
just
most of these are mine yeah yeah and
episode 14
there's deliciousness what's up you
delicious sorry
welcome back to another episode
i don't remember any of this i don't
remember this either um then we got
uh new people big pp nations
[Music]
because like no i laughed at that one
because i was like oh this was ten times
funnier in my head
the moment i said out loud it was like
the moment saying 69
yeah yeah the moment i said it out loud
i was like this isn't funny
but it made it on here somehow and then
apparently we have episode 40 43 and 44
so we had like
three apparently banger intro yeah wow
about that so this is the crazy
combination
i wonder which i wasn't very happy
because i was like good joe you're gonna
get demonetised i think this episode
yeah that's right it wasn't my idea god
told me to say it why would you believe
him if god told you to put your hand in
the fire would you do it
god like quietly was like you should say
this at the beginning i don't know what
you're talking about
then joey's like john travolta meme
looking around the room why is it
demolition
on youtube come on and then we got
episode 43 connor shit's on his phone
i don't know okay i can already tell
this is not me
so this is this is connor intro i
actually wash my phone
like once once a week i don't like you
it gets like [ __ ] on it i don't really
like it
[ __ ] on my phone melee i don't remember
that i don't remember that either
i don't remember that like that was like
five five six weeks ago i'm [ __ ] yeah
right i don't remember saying that
and then we got the final one episode 44
uh ladybug
i remember this one i remember this one
i don't out of every intro this was the
only one i remember this is the weirdest
injury yeah by far
play played play the clip all right and
we're live in five
four three
hello everyone i love the edit on this
how it just slowly fades into yeah
it's go slowly going live i don't
remember this at all
to be fair the entire ladybug episode is
a fever dream to me
it it is like i don't know how you
handled sitting next to him right
i did like did you see how quiet i was
in that episode
i didn't handle it like i i i just
remember the ladybird episode because
they just took me back so much
about how much energy was just radiating
for the guy yeah
it was that episode where i was like oh
we we really must be like low energy on
our episodes yeah
well either that or this guy i think i
think we have an appropriate amount of
energy i
think i think ladybird has far too much
energy
for any one human being to have that's
true yeah yeah yeah you just you just i
feel like maybe he's siphoning everyone
else's energy yeah it could just feel
like tired around here yeah yeah
how do you do this this is impressive so
uh which one do you think is the winner
guys well let's let's let's give our uh
i mean
i mean i mean let's let's pretend that
we did it actually
let's just talk about our favorite one
though yeah what's your favorite one um
i honestly don't have a horse in this
race this isn't a category that i feel
too passionate about
i'm gonna be honest with you guys this
is one that i might you know i don't
really mind who wins this one yeah
a lot i'm in most of these horses yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what's your opinion
joey yeah but the thing is i'm most of
these horses and yet i
don't really care either all of my
interest is just as dumb as the next
true true oh i'm like five so i'm like
big pp nation
hilarious yeah that's i hope that one
works yeah i i hope big pp nation or
salty salmon slices just because it
started the tradition but uh
ladybird i guess i don't know that's
just weird it was like a fifa dream like
i said
all right do you want to play the cards
right here who won joey
all right and the bulldog is suspended
the winner for the trash tastes
award-winner best intro goes to
what was the percentage that it won by
do we know how many votes did it get of
x amount trying to bring up the stacks
now okay i'm glad that we can continue
it gives you a
pie chart though yeah yeah it's loading
i think this is too many responses
i'm glad that we can confirm that our
audience are as just mentally young as
we are yeah as mentally young as i am
yeah
everyone's just immature which i which
is guess what which is why i guess
everyone loves talking about [ __ ] here
i wonder if it's a case of like people
didn't really feel that strongly about
any particular intro and it had the
funniest name
i wonder well yeah it's because if i saw
this i think i would see
you know salty salmon slices i sleep
peepee nation okay yeah
okay okay can i just can i just say
opening this
up feels so good oh i'm looking forward
to my turn
again ashley did these for us yeah looks
so nice that looks
so good shall we go to the next board
then what is what is the next one let's
go to the next one yeah yeah
what are the stats uh it won with 22.6
of the vote with 22.6 of the votes what
was the next one what was the closest
one
closest one was uh lady beard of course
21.8
oh wow one percent difference it's about
200 votes
about 200 wow big pp nation won by 200
rise on bing tv
confirmed the only thing that can beat
ladybird is big ppb nation
what's the difference he's the leader of
the
nation all right let's go to the next
category let's go to the next one
hot take of the year wow we're getting
right into well this is getting getting
out the big guns already
i have a feeling that i i can't remember
what the nominations are even though we
chose them
yeah i feel that most of these are gone
because god has like god has
just the [ __ ] stupidest takes he does
like god
god is a very god is a very smart and
wise man and then sometimes god says
sometimes he's like a little too woke
you know yeah or it's like where did
that come from
i'm just too woke when it comes to like
my food opinions apparently
because i i feel like that's yeah that's
based as [ __ ] dude
we'll see we'll see we'll see let's get
on to the nominations what are the
nominations
oh okay okay so the first one we have is
cross the worst part of the pizza and i
don't eat them let's play
the clip why why does crust on pizza
exist and why does everyone pretend
it tastes good no it doesn't
what a clown i still stick to this
opinion to this day
you know what like i think i think i
remember when i tweeted this out and i
think people who got cancelled
get less hate than when i tweeted this
out like i thought i knew
what a hot take was until i tweeted it
out and i don't think
i've had more replies to a single tweet
than this one
but you know it was the first time i
looked at a tweet and i was like this is
why we needed a dislike button
it's frankly you know i hate to use it
it's just it's a cringe opinion it's
crazy like
you know if you want to you know i have
some opinions where i don't like
something but i recognize that i'm in
the wrong store
you know and i think that you should
kind of you know come to terms with it
that you're just wrong
right you know what it's uh it's after
this episode i've gotten like so many
secret messages
from like friends you've just been like
you know what are actually
across the anonymous actually i actually
kind of agree with you you know what i'd
like to cross the resistance i will be i
will be the pizza cross
martyr so that all of us
who are who the crossless gang can exist
i will be the [ __ ] martyr
so that people will know
yourself it's like you need the crust
right so when you're eating like you get
a little break
from just pizza like as much as good
pizza is you get sick of eating
one noted flavor exactly except you can
dip it in the garlic
the wrench whatever you do you know it's
a fantastic oh with ranch it's it's game
over so yeah no but
okay it's like that's the point right if
you need to have like stuffed crust
or dipping sauce or whatever then that
just means you need to be sort of
it's a bonus that's like saying like oh
you could make the same argument why put
a pizza on the bread you know it's all
you know
yeah that's like saying like why put
anything on bread when you could just
eat the bread if the bread is such an
inferior ingredient why would you put
ingredients on top of it you know
oh because the crust is just bread
unwise why do i not put any viscous
breakfast spreads on my bread
if if if i just eat the bread if the
bread is great then why do you need
like you know why do you need something
why everyone stand on base ingredients
like
are you trying to get like another
nomination on this one
i've chosen i heal to die on and i'm
dying on this hill okay
and a hill that i'm not proud of is uh
the next one which is
i think steak is [ __ ] mid play the
clue all right i don't like steak
oh my god i think steak is [ __ ] mid
no man
okay okay that that was an opinion where
you know when you
you hear something you double take
you're like wait what yeah that was like
the blinking means
do you still stand by that tank um okay
yes in a sense okay but that but like i
say it's mid look okay i don't say
steak is look sounds like backpedaling
because it is
steak is me i didn't say it was bad i'll
still
eat a steak but it's not it's inherent
but it's not
it's not my goat no one has ever been
happy about being called mid
in any capacity if i were to go out and
have like all right let's have like
a slab of meat for a meal right like
chicken pork beef whatever like however
you cook or whatever
steak for me is like option number five
or six no
no no no steak is like the top tier like
if if we're talking about slab
money is no issue yeah no okay so after
this episode went up i actually went to
a really nice steak place in akihabara
yeah where i was like
all right it went up a few places i
think backpedal of the year yeah next
year trash takes yeah
over the years nothing can be a good
steak and i remember when i first heard
this like if my ears could vomit that's
what they would be doing
man i think i think what this just
proved is that i just grew up eating
really mid steak
like i probably didn't have like a nice
thing i'm sorry father your steaks were
pretty mean and then actually it's
great because you also have another
shitty opinion oh yeah this one
i think bacon is just not that great
wait was it was this joey this is joey
i thought it was you both i thought it
was you play the clip play clay play the
clip
bacon is the cheapest part of the pit
right right right and it's [ __ ] and
gammon's like the actual bacon is the
best part of the pig
thank
[Applause]
you know because i remember i was on the
other side of this argument well no i do
i mean i agree that it's not that great
too far
yeah it's not that great it's [ __ ]
great everyone loves bacon
steak is above bacon for me it's it's
like wait it's like i don't agree with
that i weigh this much
okay i agree with that steak is above
bacon the steak's one of the best meats
but
bacon is just like no no steak is like
in the middle and bacon's below them
oh my god i still okay i backpedal the
steak argument i stand by this bacon
argument any other part of the pig is
better
yeah like any other part belly shoulder
that's what i'm like everything you know
you remember like back in 2012 when it
was like a personality trait to say that
you like bacon
do you remember that when that was the
thing the epic meal time yeah yeah meal
time yeah
oh i like bacon i'm i'm quirky
all right you like a widely available
cheap product okay cool is cheeseburger
no i has
bacon cheeseburgers just you know i
think uh i i think it's been
sold to us a little too much by these
these corporations yeah
they've got bacon on everything they
make it seem like it's amazing it's not
it's really cool it is amazing
it's
out of every like part of the pig you
cook bacon people know you're cooking
bacon why because it smells [ __ ]
great
it gets the taste buds but the the
flavor is just good
the flavor the flavor tastes like the
smell and you're just like
that's why they don't make [ __ ] bacon
ramen dude they make it out of the other
part of the pigs
way more flavor way more flavorful
there's so much more richness going on
come on god come on i'm going to argue
with the cause all right let's look at
this last one
though uh to me music is just beeps and
boots these two of these are mine
two of these are corners i guess i think
i actually am like a caveman when it
comes to music i'm like oh
the beeps in the boobs are very pleasing
music goes boop
i think this was the start of the monkey
brain meme wasn't it yeah it was
literally the
wait what is that just how you feel you
were a man
and then this episode you went down well
i mean
i also got a lot of messages people are
like yeah i totally understand what you
mean they're like it's the same for me
i felt like i meant i i met i don't know
no no i i know if you
feel with a piece across this fellow
just like
you know that meme where it's the the
the like the just the black outline of
the person the brain caved in yeah
that's that's the crust one
the monkey one is the brain with the
chair sitting on his ear
yeah yeah i mean you know it is what i
feel like this is just like
uh i don't know if it's like genetic
mental whatever it is i
i literally cannot care about music no
no i completely get this one because so
like for me this isn't so much of a hot
day because i know plenty of people like
that
it's just i've never heard anyone else
describe it as
beeps yeah i i would say i would say out
of all of these this is
not so much a take yeah you know i mean
yeah it's also
because when i used to try to explain
like yeah i don't really listen to the
lyrics like oh what why
and then eventually i just realized just
say you like the [ __ ] beeps and the
boobs
i already think it's a hard take to be
honest yeah you guys i mean look let's
be real i
i probably already know what the winner
of this one is going to be i mean i
think it's a unanimous vote
i'd be very surprised if it's not what i
think it's going to be can we can we
can we appreciate that three of these
came from one episode
and can we appreciate that three of
these are from
no there's three different episodes but
three of them are food opinions
i thought they were all from the same
episode these are all from different
episodes yeah
they're all from different episodes oh
my god i thought all of them are from
the food episode
but we just talked about food that often
we talk about food weight differing
opinions that often yeah these are all
from different episodes
this episode is sponsored by atsco
gentlemen what is that drip you've got
on there what are you wearing joey
what are you doing i thought you'd never
notice well i'm wearing the
cowboy bee ball beanie as you can see
i'm wearing jojo i'm also don't pay
attention to joey
i'm also wearing jojo nice trip god
thank you good night
no nice trip to no you nice trip to you
thank you to atsco and they're
officially licensed apparel and
accessories from all your favorite anime
tell us what amazing series atscos has
to offer aggretsuko attack on titan
avatar banana black covert book
black clover bleach dr stone a lot more
this is an alphabetical order we only
just got to d so you can imagine
how many series they have including jojo
there are tons of new exclusives not
found
anywhere else and there are new items
every week
and gentlemen you boys know i love my
drip i love my jojo sweater i'm never
taking it off
i'm gonna sleep in it i'm gonna bathe it
i'm gonna do everything in it and thank
god that i got ten percent off with a
coupon code trash chase
after checkout i'm so goddamn happy
everybody claps
plus you can catch us go online or at
both new york comic con and anime nyc
later this year so keep your eyes peeled
so go to asco.com
just click the link in the description
to gets your drip today
and don't forget to use coupon code
trash taste for ten percent off hell
yeah nice read gone nice
nice thank you very much back to the
episode oh my god drip
all right let's uh i guess let's get to
the announcement there yeah uh i think
this is
me yeah it'll be the top of your pilot
hot take of the year
and the trash taste hot take of the year
goes
to crust cross cross oh my god
the music is just the beeps and the
boobs
what how did that work what the [ __ ]
what an upset
i was what an absolute upset what
how
[Music]
i thought this was going to be the
lowest one yeah i thought so yeah can we
get the statistics
of that this one with 37.5 37.5
of the votes wait what was the second
place second place was steak is [ __ ]
mid
where did the pizza christ come that was
third oh my god there's too many
crossless [ __ ]
i was right crossless gang
rise up crossless gang rise up [ __ ] is
wrong with our viewers why would you not
vote this clown
the resistance was too large gentlemen i
have a dream
that one day [ __ ] off one day you will
not be judged
for your preference of food but for your
love of
the scene is this how britannia felt
like
a dream that one day the cross this gang
and the cross gang and maybe even the
only cross gang
can sit on the same table in peace thank
you very much
the moment i go to a restaurant there's
an option for crustless i am walking
yeah i'm done i'm like what do you do
what happened
i've never been so [ __ ] proud in my
life right now i'm so sad
this is how britannia felt when lelouch
came through right
how did i get there they're so much
bigger than i thought they were going to
be
next category next category [ __ ] i
don't want to see this [ __ ] anymore
all right let's get the next category
out i can't believe it best out of
context clip
oh i i i oh this this should be an
interesting so many good ones
yeah you mean you mean fifty percent of
the subreddit is this well i think i
think what we should do we should just
let play all the clips not say anything
yeah yeah yeah yeah as you would
experience
yeah it's out of context so these are
the top four nominations of best
out of context clip bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang
that one for the longest time i didn't
know what episode
no i knew exactly what episode was that
was from because i remember
i remember doing this actually and i'm
just like wait [ __ ]
i probably shouldn't have done that it's
a gift it's immortalized
there is no way you stand by that i
stand by it oh god
what i love about this clip is that the
way you say with such conviction yeah
it's like him out of nowhere
i stand by this yeah and this one is
actually from one of the trash taste
streams which if you're not following
our third channel then you would have
probably
subscribed to this one when i worked at
[ __ ] mcdonald's like that wasn't
challenging and i'd go home and i'd be
like right now i want to be like [ __ ]
mentally challenged yeah that sounds
awful
it was a very poor choice of words yeah
very very important i was just like
freezing the clip that was terrible you
could have said that
and then this one oh this might be my
favorite bug this one this i think to
this day is still the highest
rate what why is this the top rated clip
on reddit
is very funny yeah play it but that one
that just sticks out to you it's just
like
you meet somebody or i should i guess
specify that one convention story where
somebody
was the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah because
get someone who looks at you the way god
looks at the corona
do you remember why you could not
remember this what were you thinking
about
i have no [ __ ] clue because the thing
is like this
this is like a clip where you know it's
you know you know when you just do
things when someone else is talking and
you forget that you're on camera i have
no idea what the [ __ ] i was doing just
kind of hope that when you do something
weird that it's on someone else
like i do not remember what i was
thinking i was thinking you know sydney
was probably
probably talking no one's like
concentrating on me um
and if if it wasn't for trash taste then
this would have never been filmed
and it's now like the highest rated post
on reddit why
i don't know why this is so funny
there's so many other good [ __ ] clips
and
fan art and everything and this this is
the top clip of all time
what it's because the mind boggles right
it's like what was he thinking there
like what was going on in his hand like
what made him laugh at that moment it's
like the inside out meme where they go
like i wonder what he's thinking about
which one do you want to win boys
because i i personally i want the bang
bang bang i really want the bang bang
bang i really love that one
it's just it's such a it literally
encapsulates out of condition
perfectly i think i i i want the i'd
rather something up my ass and down
that is a good one just just because
just because it was like such it came
out [ __ ] nowhere
and that line hit like a truck i'm just
like what the [ __ ]
then i don't even remember saying that
all right should we find out who won
gentlemen all right let's find out
best out of context the best out of
context clip goes to
gone realizes he's drinking corona yes
thank you son thank you we did a
subreddit and that's right this is from
episode 20.
your uploads were not put in vain get
this off the top rated get it off
stop uploading this get this off i
wanted there how much did it win by a
landslide was it
was it was it not even 36.56
that's pretty good what was the second
place one dart without context
got without contact how much of the vote
oh wow oh wow 22.9 percent was the
second best one because
the subreddit came through god clearly
is just the most out of context person
in trash takes obviously
like this i've never had to deal with
this with my in my life before right
because i've never had it
i'm never on camera because i had never
had the camera pointed them to me so i
didn't know i was doing this [ __ ] and
now i'm just like
man i do a lot of weird [ __ ] when i'm
not thinking
[Music]
you know what the day that this that
something tops this for like the top
rated post of all time i'm actually
going to open a bottle of champagne
yeah yeah i'm excited i wonder what
could top this what could possibly top
the wholesomeness of garten just
laughing at a corrupt there's a part of
me that just forever wants this to be
the top you know
for as long as you do trash tapes i
don't want this to be important
all right let's move on to the next
category next category screen grab of
the year
this is a good one there's so many good
ones
yeah this is one of the like it could
easily be like a 15
nominee yeah there's so many good ones
and there's just
every single week i get a laugh just
seeing at this time yeah yeah yeah but
there are some ones
every time i go into the subreddit
there's a new screen
episode this is a new
the barack obama giving yourself a medal
meme yeah because i i can't recreate
this
have you seen like the gif of it like
the build up to it is even better
what episode is this from the the food
video the the seven
what were we describing what was like i
was joking about peasants or something
and being rich and i was like
like somehow somehow
i can't i can't recreate it like no
matter how much i try like
it's got about it's got about seven
different emotions like all packed in
the one i can't
it's just like the perfect emotion yeah
and then we got
uh me stirring the emission this is from
the stream from the stream right it's
just me fingering pickerel juice yeah i
completely forgot about the screen grab
until i got nominated again
and then we got uh degenerates versus
normies we can't see we can't see the
entire one we'll have to show you the
full thing on screen right now yeah but
it's pretty good it was used in a lot of
memes
and then we have uh i think dance
favorite right yeah this is this is this
is uh
this is one of this is also one of my
favorites cherry looking up the skirt on
me
this is like this like the equivalent of
like the corona bottle thing where you
didn't realize you were on camera
because you guys were talking about it
and i had it in my hand i was like i'm
just curious i'm like she wearing pants
let's see let's find out
it was just such a cultured man moment
yes hello
i'm a fellow gentleman of culture yeah
the men couldn't wait until we were off
camera
he was like i have to look right now
because you two were talking
i thought
don't know and your face is out of
disgust what i love about
i love this photo because it's usually
paired with the iphone
right i feel like i'm the gentleman
versus the pedal
i feel like this is just yin and yang
you know what i mean
oh man i don't know all of these are so
good like i
i wouldn't be upset if any of these uh
lost i mean i think
the wine one is probably the most iconic
yeah i feel like that one might win
that probably my like my personal
favorite was the degenerates versus
normies
it's just such a perfect such a perfect
juxtaposition yeah and i'm
and i'm glad it was the one it was like
you can see that me and sydney were on
the same wavelength i can't even
remember
this moment but i'm just like there's
nothing that encapsulates when me and
sydney hang out with these two more than
like
this one screencast every time we hang
out there's some other other screen
grabs i like like we had the uh
the uh one where the cycling special
where gantt was cycling and i'm out the
window smiling yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the one where me and
jerry are sitting uh in the
the chairs watching oh yeah that got
turned into a meme
yeah that made its rounds oh yeah yeah
yeah i also like the one where uh
ladybird is like sharing the mic
oh yeah yeah it's like whispering that
was really good
there's so many good ones but all right
but there can only be one winner ladies
and gentlemen green grab of the gear
let's go trash taste the water screen
grab of the year goes to
the corner
i can't read it it's classic did this
one win by a lot i'm i'm
i assume this one's gonna win by a
landslide
wait what was the second place uh second
place was um
sydney oh okay okay
this was the iconic one of the year that
was i think used the most
like one of those north korean-esque
shrine pictures of this
it's just like that in the office an
army needs to walk past this phone it's
my british pay tribute
patriot to the wyoming this is probably
the one
there are some of them where i was like
i'm pretty sure i know it yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're actually on many where i
think i know no no this was one of them
just because i've seen this picture so
many times
i just get like five replies of this
it's the perfect reaction i'm not even
mad
you know what i like of me i seeing it
it's funny i like it
if that was me i would have just a great
[ __ ] face
i feel like i don't even see me when i
look at it i just see a funny ass
reaction
i don't know why it's just like the
perfect twitchy mode you know
it's one of my twitter all right let's
move on to the next category next one
most degenerative moment oh god god
knows this this was one of the hardest
categories to pick from i think
yeah there's just so many [ __ ]
degenerate
[Music]
degenerates here men of men of culture
all right let's look at the nominees
all right we got uh we got two failings
three minutes three three by three
and this is a true degenerate moment god
that just like
i i was like so impressed by this three
by three
because we didn't we didn't share it
beforehand and i didn't know how hard
maelin was going to go
i love how much this clip exploded as
well the clip is like 300 000 views or
something like that
it's actually roots it's actually
ridiculous you did it mainly
because i i think it just shut it like
everyone had this image of maelyn being
like okay
she she's prim and proper she brought
the boys together and then she reveals
like this she drops his [ __ ]
bombshell a degenerate
these videos or videos oh [ __ ] play it
play them up
monster from the new world utano prince
summer jojo vampire knight golden kamui
story of sayon koko sores and hakuoki
what i remember about this moment is
when melin talked about her body pillows
yeah and i think it was like how many is
like there's like 50 people
and she put cents on them yeah yeah and
i i think it was the first time where
all three of us were just like
gobsmacked so we just there was like
just a five second
silence where we were just like what the
[ __ ] did we just hear
isn't there that picture of me that's
like i'm just making this round from
this moment
and then obviously we have the next one
which is uh this is
and it was just like this giant fleshy
it's it's this fleshy giant
roll of a bunch of cookies
that's all you need to know that's
that's all the context you need that's
the
three degenerate there you go that was a
five second sales pitch on your channel
oh god and joey's
and then the next one is this is
let's just play it let's just play it i
really like a i really like elf girls
and i really like tanks
dude dark-skinned elf girls dark-skinned
elf dark-skinned
elf girls man replace every hentai with
a dark-skinned elf
i stand by this fair enough that was i
feel like this clip went very fair on
joey this this could have been one where
he's talking about gangbang
one where he was just being nice this is
the [ __ ] like predator meme with like
the muscley guys like handshaking like
god939
under the table right now that was such
a fun argument i think i think the
hentai episode was definitely like one
of
like the most fun to film yeah as like a
as like a host and
i remember filming this and just losing
my [ __ ] mind
yeah this is a very good episode there's
another one actually from that same
episode oh yeah three of these are from
the hentai episode
yeah oh yeah it is three yeah yeah
because we got like uh
steve handjobs all right uh let's play
the next one play next one
how does anyone get on to get uh get off
to this in like 2020 well first of all
uh i don't really care about like
animation it's more like yeah no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] listen i i also saw a funny
thing the other day about madness best
someone posted on the subreddit they
were like oh
someone bought a copy of mother knows
breast they should tell connor so they
can get a physical copy
and it was like my picture of my
physical cop really my mother knows best
i think they grabbed off google images
and i was like it's mine i own the
physical copy
i should let you know about your own
physical yeah
hey guys should get in touch with this
guy yeah
he's like oh really i do yeah
this one's good out of context it puts
me off so that's why i chromecast
i'm just gonna message you every hour
now just hoping that i'll catch you
that's why that's why i chromecast it to
my tv
listen i stand by it's convenient you
still do that yeah of course
like i [ __ ] changed my ways after
this episode came out now
how you can tell someone lives by
themselves living up with a significant
other i would like my partner to
understand what
what i
all right and then there's the last one
oh man this is from the figurine
oh yeah i remember it being
way over my budget how much this was a
hundred and seventy dollars
see you s we say degenerative moment
this god got the w
i know i i i was just cause i remember
you both were playing the game and i'm
just like i just want to see titty um
and it somehow
ended up [ __ ] she [ __ ] solo
carried my performance right sorry did
you titty's one man the team has
prevailed
exactly oh man this is hard this is so
hard
i'm fine with any of them winning this
one yeah really honestly these are all
just as degenerate i
i can't pick i i'm glad i didn't have to
pick i i
hope the viewers picked yeah all i hope
is that at least one of the ones from
the hentai episode one right because
that would be thematic yeah i think that
would be thematic all right all right
and the winner of the most degenerate
moment
is please not me sit snubs [ __ ] on the
round table
i mean wow relatively speaking
understandable that's about as
degenerative
yet understandable well she just earned
the title of the queen of degeneracy
yeah congratulations she's living by her
name
yeah was it was it a landslide was it
close what was it how close was this
this was she won with 32.3 oh wow that's
quite a bit
six nominations six nominations
three point two percent pretty pretty
possible pretty comfortable margin yeah
wow
congratulations congratulations sydney
there you go sydney you can you can hold
on to the title
loud and proud no doubt we'll be getting
a tweet about this yeah
exactly okay live live tweet off this
entire episode from sydney
what is the next category actually
saltiest moment oh there's many there's
many
choices the amount of sodium this year
was very fast i actually don't even
again i forgot what the nominations were
there's
so many i get angry about everything
yeah so yeah
frankly anything well i mean every
episode we rant about something
exactly what are the nominations ashley
please do let us know
uh connor after lucy it's likely
play the clip play the club or cup to
when we're not dead
yeah all right boys i have to ask one
question how does it feel to be a
cheater
a dirty little cheetah i feel good
i hate how this actually turns like a
full-on argument yeah yeah amongst the
viewers
even though i didn't even cheat people
were saying i did i can't believe it
right all right
keep telling yourself you can see the
souls radiated this day
yeah we didn't cheat either we just
played the game like differently
oh this next one is from one of the live
streams actually
three of these oh yeah three of these
are fun live streams none of these are
from normal episodes
three of these these are from normal
these are all from live streams i guess
i guess this is just like the trash
tastes
dark highlighter catch up right trash
yeah yeah there's only three episodes
there also follow us on twitch if you
want to catch these live yeah yeah but
uh play the second one this is from the
crunchyroll anime awards
i'm not okay i'm not okay i'm not
dissing kagia
but i am not okay i'm still not okay
about this i like the fact that conor
tried to like
justify this you know i you know we were
sponsored i was trying to
try to try to keep the ball rolling
cause i was like i understand we were
sponsored and i i knew that's what
you're trying to do and i'm just like i
cannot stop you
you can do it and then i'll i'll like
i'll like save you know
there's also there's also a great moment
in that that from the livestream where
it's like jerry was
saying something i was like shut the
[ __ ] up joey don't say anything
oh yeah yeah this also
gave like a really good out of context
screenshot when it was just like my
visible disappointment and joey just
looking at me
[ __ ] like closing it yeah just losing
it yeah i
think it could be easily green screen
guys i honestly did not even
care i was just loving the fact that god
was being so
salty this next one when wales doesn't
have the best flag
we have the coolest flag yeah it's just
straight up like you can't deny that
right
england flag boring wells flag [ __ ]
dragon
like shit's a badass and there's a cool
story behind it i
i remember this was the first live
stream as well i don't know if this
counts as a salty moment as much as it
was just yet another trash talk
argument that was quite salty yeah this
clip this clip is like kind of the
beginning of
and then he ran and it kind of ran for
about 45 minutes yeah i was very
just being like no guys no no yeah it
was it was it was the focus of the live
stream
i wouldn't let it change that's right
because we also went on to like top 10
flags yeah yeah yeah wales was on none
of them
did joey wake up and choose to be a
karen
what do you mean i don't know if that
means letting me laugh
jerry got so angry about this no no no i
didn't it wasn't even me being angry
honestly
okay look let me let me let me reiterate
all right
i love this i wasn't even angry oh my
god
i wasn't even salty i just was confused
because it came out of nowhere i i okay
it was like one person in the chat said
that you picked it up at the time and
then everyone was like at the time
i remember the context but now i
freaking yeah right i can't remember the
context i don't even know what i said
that
turned me into karen but apparently i
became a cat
and then he got annoyed i got annoyed
because i was like
explain yourself there's no explanation
explain twist chat explain yourself all
right
i [ __ ] love that moment who who'd you
guys what do you guys want to win oh god
any of these could win honestly i
honestly i want the joke i i think i
think
the saltiest moment is actually connor
losing at cycling yeah but the one that
still makes me laugh to this day
i wouldn't be surprised every time we
mention it all right gamers let's find
out who won
all right who's watching the saltiest
moment of the year
all right ready gamers
oh it is the connor when wales doesn't
have the best
can we get the results yeah thirty six
point six percent thirty six
what was the second second place second
was common losing exactly
oh wow i'm just the saltiest trash taste
member yeah clearly enough
wow so what we prefer and what our
audience before clearly is very
different
i was very salty i was very very salty
i'm surprised that there are that many
trash taste after dark viewers this
might be a reoccurring theme where
you know perhaps uh some recency with
the stuff might
might play into the voting maybe because
the more recent yeah yeah yeah but the
wales one was the first live stream so
that was ageless and i i think we did no
one's really talked about it on the
subreddit or even mentioned that moment
i mean i don't know
i i mean all good moments it's very
interesting we're getting a lot of like
data right yeah what about you guys
let's go to the next one we're on number
seven
i think so yeah we're on number seven
actually next category is the most
monkey moment well i might have a bit of
an advantage in this
this is like saying this best quentin
tarantino movie and they're all quentin
tarantino movies
it's like of course who else is there
going to be
are they actually i think because there
are some very monkey moments of you
fellas okay let's let's fight
it would be like it would be like the
plot twist of the year if you didn't win
this award
well i actually think there's a good
chance that someone else could win this
one
let's look at the nominations right
let's look at the numbers shall we uh
breaking a bike play the clip look at
the beer
oh [ __ ] did you get that on camera i'm
surprised you didn't [ __ ] fall in
your arsenal
monkey has good balance i'm surprised it
wasn't the you breaking two cars because
i feel like you breaking two cars is
even more monkey than just breaking a
single bike
right oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh this was
cpu graphics card
i completely forgot about that yeah that
is pretty much
audience i properly plugged it in now
i i plugged it in
connor literally held his hand and was
like joey do this this is where you plug
it in
i was like okay father me skipping
classes
i stand by this let's play this clip i
don't know what happened to me in the
womb but like i
i can't pay attention to story and games
the moment story comes on any video game
i'm like where's the skip button
where is it really it's true it's true
as nikki jakey says you have that goopy
goblin game
man i do i can't pay attention to cut
scenes it's it's just what it is text
and dialogue and
listening reading you know there's no
gameplay make a thumbnail for my second
channel and i was like can you just like
grab a few
books for the thumbnail i was like i
don't know any books
and i was like he's like you don't like
[ __ ] i was like no i don't have any
books i just really don't own
any books yeah connor's house and my
house is the literal opposite
like manga volume i own one single manga
book
and that's just that's the experience
that's for sure yeah
uh here there's three corner moments
this yeah the vote could be split
between three
could giving joey the edge of being the
most monkey brain maybe yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
all right but there's also another one
of ladybird being a monkey
baby it is in like and i see and i say
this in the nicest way possible is
one of the hardest people to work with
oh [ __ ] to this day ladybird is the only
guest that has
like done permanent damage to our sets
he dented our [ __ ]
play button and i remember afterwards he
still like was moving around so much and
it was just like
giving me so much anxiety whenever i see
him move back and forth yeah right
you can tell he was like a proper pro
wrestler he was proper man handling that
hike that man just throws his
massive body weight around yeah because
because when we told him before the
podcast started that like you need to
have this mic
up to your face he was like got it just
[ __ ] grabbed it like this and was
like okay so
uh we normally have to turn guest's
microphone up yeah we're not used to it
but we actually have to turn this down
which is a first and i think it'll be a
last honestly yeah i had a better handle
of that microphone to do with my life
like it was like it was impressive
honestly all right and then this last
one is an absolute classic trash taste
oh yeah sometimes if i'm like real angry
some days or i wake up and i'm upset
i'll just go in the mirror
and i'll be like come on
i still do that i still do that
sometimes you've got to do it my
neighbors probably don't appreciate it
yeah absolutely frankly they're probably
in a war yeah so who cares
exactly it's just like it's it's
sometimes i just hear some lines from
you and it's
your like brain is just like literally
that monkey picture that's just like
neuron activation right
that is that is that like sometimes when
i see some of the stuff you do it's just
that literal picture yeah
all right so which one do you think is
going to win guys i have
a feeling it's going to be one of
conor's but i secretly hope me with the
gpu
honestly on paper it's the gpus the most
monkeys right
out of every one of these single moments
it's the gpu one i think i am body
monkey
yeah the dumbest moment yeah the
standout one
in my opinion it's the juxtaposition and
again like i said i think because people
who might think
i'm the most monkey they might spread
their votes out yeah i think there's a
chance
because because these ones are just like
monkey moments but i think like you
literally regressed in evolution when
you did this yeah
like
yeah this is this is like momentary
monkey this is five years monkey
all right all right i have the winner
right here though let's find out trash
chase the water where most monkey moment
goes to
on youtube let's go
you know what i ain't even mad i ain't
even mad the upsets
the ups the upset fantastic great moves
wow
was this a landslide not really thirty
one
point two percent so the only one okay
what what came last oh what came next
yeah
okay what came next was conor skipping
cutscenes connor skipping cut scenes and
then okay i think last was ladybird
oh yes yeah my theory was right yeah
yeah yeah
votes was spread out yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then ladybird is just like that was
just
one monkey moment out of a two and a
half hour monkey yeah
i'm glad you won that one take the dog
i'll take the dolphin i'm really happy
you won that one i'm glad you won that
one as well this is the moment
this is the most honorable dishonorable
mention i've ever gotten i mean it was
just like i'd say it's an upset but it
was also well deserved well deserved
well deserved
well done me give myself one
what's the next category gentlemen let's
find out let us find out yes
sorry story oh man there's so many great
stories that we've told
give me some more wine all right i'll
hit you all i can't even remember half
the stories we tell
i mean it's just we all just come to the
table with some great stories what can i
say
that's why you guys watch the episodes
right i know i
i think it's the stories it was the
stories that first distinguished trash
taste from like
an anime podcast and everyone was just
like wait we don't give a [ __ ] about
them talking about anime
just give us more stories give us more
stories my parents sometimes uh
message me like connor you you got that
wrong what the one detail wrong
yeah yeah i guess it doesn't matter i
get that all the time yeah yeah it
doesn't matter
i get that from my parents as well so i
don't know they always remember
differently yeah yeah but let's look at
the nominees for this one
yeah all right so
i can't just play it just play the clip
this is so much so good
i don't want context that was the point
where we basically
him and i we found out that we found out
from each other that we're into
those kinds of shows we're just into
each other yeah like it keeps getting
worse and worse though
yeah i didn't even do that on purpose i
was like how do i how do i structure the
story
like because i i was like i was i
remember like losing it when you were
telling the story because i was like
there's no way he is not doing this on
purpose
right and it just kept getting worse and
worse and if it was not like the
if if it wasn't the award for best out
of context moment yeah this was just the
best out of context
like story story like everything like
this encapsulates everything about out
of context
[ __ ] amazing and that that one little
clip doesn't do this entire story just
go watch the full clip on the highlights
but uh what's the next one
a huge dong during his job interviews my
career is on the line here
i just want to get a job what he what
could you possibly be laughing at
and then i look at what i've drawn i've
drawn a penis
i love that clip that clip is so good
that's such a good story oh my gosh
i still like i remember telling that
story and my parents didn't know that
that happened during my job
so they found out that that was the
reason i got rejected from my first job
interview
from watching trash taste oh yeah a very
stern text from your mom
followed that's how you keep the fans
coming you know you gotta get a teasing
with that
uh and then this one just inspired an
entire special didn't yeah
play the clip play the club how i ended
up in playing professional chess was
weird to begin with because i never
like played it much i just liked video
games a lot yeah i mean
it was it was a very long story and i i
think this was less of like a funny
story more of just like
this is like a character development
stuff yeah right yeah that was like one
of the clips that i feel that people
like what the [ __ ]
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] yeah
because i remember you telling that
story to me beforehand and i was just
like
you've got to tell this somewhere yeah
this is an amazing [ __ ] story
and i'm glad that people really enjoyed
it like i remember when that clip came
out or the episode came out people like
whoa
they really went round with us i mean
you know and then chess.com hit us up
after
yeah yeah yeah and then entire chest
tournament
this is such a great story i love this
out of so many poop stories that
we've told on this podcast i think this
is probably my favorite people so
disgusting
getting that [ __ ] putting it in a
halloween a pumpkin sorry
and throwing the pumpkin at one of my
friend's windows
and it just exploded that's one of those
stories where it's like
this story would have been a hundred
times funny if you were there yeah yeah
but it's still hilarious it's hilarious
it's like disgusting in the moment yeah
like the moment you get to tell it the
first time yeah it's just hilarious
how [ __ ] absurd this thing and how
funny it is and also
that i bought my poor mate who was like
two windows over for me
who had to clean that [ __ ] up because
the school said they would take them a
week to get there
take all the weeks to get
second character development story i
guess normally when you want to
give your family like good karma
everyone in my family has been a monk
like twice in their life
everyone in my family what happened
there
yeah check the suit check the suit
see i mean this was i guess this is the
first time i've ever talked about being
a monk
in public despite how long i've been on
the internet and eve like
i know i remember because even for the
longest time even for like my closest
friends
nobody knew i was a monk yeah and i
can't remember who you told me this
story yeah yeah and you had to like
drag it out of me yeah because i was
like what
what because i don't know anyone around
me who used to be a monk
that's [ __ ] cool yeah yeah i love how
at this
rate my character development is me
literally coming out to my friend
that is your character that's my
character he was just like i was a
degenerate i still am a degenerate but i
always will be that i got very
homoerotic with my friend while watching
kisses
and then what's the last clip there i
can't see the last one
oh the most awkward elevator ride ever
oh yeah this is my story this is a good
one
for the accident alone yeah door opens
and this like black guy walks in he
walks in really quietly door closes
starts going down and then he just goes
oh yeah everybody shuts up when the
edward walks in
i can just i can only just fathom oh you
can't make that [ __ ] up
what i love about the story is like how
i can relate to that story even though i
wasn't there yeah because i can
exactly see that moment happening like
that could have happened to any one of
us
to this day that is still the scariest
experience i had in america
like hands down but for like a different
reason yeah oh my god like honestly
what's gonna win i have no i i i i i
can't pick one
because like it's a nice mixture right
because it's a mixture of like really
hilarious moments versus like really
kind of wholesome deep moments yeah
i think that maybe the monk one will win
maybe i feel like that's the most iconic
i don't know i'm thinking either the
monk one or the chess pro one i mean
in terms of like the stories people
remember the monk one and the chess when
i feel stand out because that's like
played a huge part in like our
characters true true true
um but i mean i feel like i feel like
there were even more stories than this
that we didn't get to put in our
nominations oh absolutely because there
were like there were so there's been so
many good stories that i've
told and you guys have told over the
years that i don't even remember all of
them right now
so i can't pick one honestly this is
[ __ ] difficult
yeah oh yeah it's me you can't make it
so that's just fine i did win
oh i'm glad i didn't have to pick
because the view is picked
and the best story of the year goes
to connor becoming a chessboard
yeah okay i mean look it inspired an
entire special yeah
it makes lots this is deep in the trash
taste yeah all right
it is like this this one probably has
one of the most effects on like
the trash taste lore and [ __ ]
character development because i feel
like what is this [ __ ] screen crap
because i i even feel like this was the
first big story told on this podcast i
think so yeah
yeah i i how much did it win by though
what's the second second place one place
was god's penis with 26 percent
don't say godzilla that's penises
yeah honestly gantt could win this one i
could win i thought i was going to win
this one for the crosstalk
i think all three of us all might put my
crust opinion alone but apparently that
didn't work i don't remember this
let's check out the nominations though
all right
right oh my god these photos
i love how we chose the guests oh yeah
yeah we have so we have
me connor gaunt sydney and chris i want
chris to win this one i want chris to
win this one too
i would laugh if chris won i hope chris
wins it because chris would be annoyed
about it
yeah he would joke about being annoyed
about it but he would actually be
annoyed about it
i can't get another card picture it's so
funny when was that taken that was an ax
like three years ago oh my god
and i think that picture of connor is
about six years old yeah you look so
young in that picture and this was last
week
i mean who won yeah yeah i don't think
we need to go over the nominations
this this will be pretty
self-explanatory sorry honestly i've got
to show this to the camera we're going
to get our money's worth
yeah exactly look at that i know thank
you ashley
boyce who do you think won the bet the
biggest clown
honestly any of these i honestly like as
much as i want crystal with it i kind of
think i want gone to win really
just for the crust i really don't know
for the crust it depends there's so many
different elements right yeah
i think you could also win it just for
being the monkey right yeah
let's find out let's find out all right
all right all right
[ __ ] sake
how much did i win by it's better be
neck and neck
58-15 seconds how is it a landslide what
that is the biggest win we've had yet
what
oh my god personal attack and i won't
forget this view
oh my god there's so many it's all
flooding right it's all flooding all the
reasons are flooding into my house of
course
of course he's the biggest clown it's
not like i just built a drink or
anything
god damn it i hate it here all right
enough what's the next
one what's the next one biggest
challenges
chad bigger than johnny simms oh my god
oh god all right let's look at the
nominees for this one
all right we got oh i i love that i love
the difference in the pictures here
chris broad
chris and ladybird again i love the
[ __ ] difference in photos here yeah
we had the clown photos before and now
we've got this great great job ashley
great job
do you know in the there's pictures of
those like the gigger chad picture yeah
the actual giggle chat
yeah yeah the cheap yeah you found out
like that's a real person yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah that's how i felt when i met like
ladybird i'm like
because that blew my mind when i thought
that was cg yeah everyone thought it was
ccg
and then what part of it was cg what no
no no the uh
the uh the like the giga chad meme oh
the keys to the jawline the jawline yeah
because
yeah but it was a real dude yeah
brothers and they all looked
the same yeah yeah yeah and it's
insanity and that's what it felt like
meeting ladybug yeah
he is the giga chat after all i mean i i
i would hate how ladybeard wins
yeah on paper i don't think anyone can
argue with ladybird being the biggest
shot
this isn't about being like subjective
like objectively
he is the biggest champion otherwise
it's a ladybug
like this it's the first time i've like
been in the presence of a chad and like
i know what it feels like to have your
energy sucked out and just
like taking everything just to be in the
presence that's really chatting
yeah yeah all right i have a feeling i
know who won this
all right let's find out all right trash
days award to our biggest chat it goes
to the giga chat of the year yeah
goes to ladybeard oh
well deserved well i want to know
who came last yeah that's what i want to
know so go go in order from first to
last
first ladybirds okay we have connor
connor
what chris is more chat than youtube
what
that's a [ __ ] lie what wait 36 32
uh chris had 13.
and then fourth place is gone oh jerry
i'm the least chad what came in with 4.4
at least you're not the biggest clown
joey exactly it's all good that's still
a dumb for me
it's chad i got biggest clowns what's
the point anymore
i thought there was going to be like the
dichotomy there but no
you couldn't beat the chad energy from
ladybird you know it's
it's impossible look at this this is
like this is like the final boss you see
i know i am but a mere arm hair compared
to my ladybug this is just a picture and
i'm still sitting here sweating man
like jesus things you don't want to see
at night
well-deserved put that on your cv this
guy slaps your woman on the ass what
thank you honestly i mean all right
what's the next category what's the next
category
nickname oh okay all right let's look at
the nominations
monkey brain connor
[Laughter]
is that a nickname really it's gonna be
now i guess
to your demise i am gonna quit this
podcast if that wins
uh and then we have wait did you boys
vote
huh did you give this vote i didn't vote
i didn't if i could
vote i would vote karen uh and then we
have grant for god that's not an ign
that's his real name
and then the 93 for connor honestly i
want
at this point i want karen to win do you
like any of your nicknames
what do you think what do you think
this is the most current picture where
did
this is when i did uh i think it was on
like i did like a sushi video with chris
on like a different channel this is like
four years ago
and i'm wearing like the sushi hat the
internet yeah jesus christ steve
jobs do you like that nickname guard i
[ __ ] love that [ __ ]
honestly yeah yeah yeah because um yeah
because i'm the only one out of us three
that apparently wears turtlenecks
yeah that was the first time you said
full offer i look like a rapper steve
handjobs
personally um i've been battling with
the grand nickname from my entire life
so i
really really i really hope to god that
does not win what do you think might win
here
i have no idea i feel like because i
have two nicknames it could easily be
like the vote could be split
right yeah i mean so i i would i
wouldn't be surprised if honestly like
all
i feel all of these kind of you know
scratch a different itch
for the viewer yeah i mean really i
really don't know but let's find out
connor
what's your favorite nickname of the two
steve handjobs
hell yeah i hate grant are you kidding
me
what about you for sure if that wins
unfortunately
you're going to get a new saltiest
moment of trash with the y actually what
the [ __ ] is it's m-o-n-k-e
come on come on come on that's pretty
monkey of you ashley i will say
the the one downside to having the 93
nickname is that whenever i
[ __ ] even interact publicly with a
girl everyone's like it's 93
at work no no no no no i'm just having a
conversation please stop stop
you're making it weird please yeah the
thing with about 93
is that that was something that that's
the longest lasting nickname right
because that was mentioned in episode
one episode one for this day
and i don't mind i just i just sometimes
i worry about the other person
when they like right right i'm talking
about this like connor's trying to put
the moves i'm like no
i'm literally talking to a woman please
stop who knew you could have a platonic
relationship
online and the trash tastes awardee for
best nickname
is steve jobs
[ __ ] way i'm so happy about that you
know what
i'm i'll [ __ ] take it i love that
nickname oh things i named never win
can we get the the breakdown of the post
how do you guys get a breakdown
steve jobs won with 32.3 percent 32.
it's pretty comfortable yeah second
place was connor's monkey brain
of course yeah and that place was the 93
with 19 points yeah yeah yeah i think
the vote got split yeah they all scratch
different itches right
yeah yeah yeah i think i think when you
have two ones that contend really well
i think that vote might be split because
i think steve hand jobs is better than
grant
yeah i think it's easier to vote for i
think sorry no bias there i think it's
better
it's it's it's definitely better i'm so
[ __ ]
glad brian came like last right did he
come last
uh grant no grant was fourth karen
are you happy joey are you happy i love
you guys
gamers gamers pc gamers we have an extra
special stream coming up next week
conor give us the details i'm glad you
asked on on the 2nd of june in japan
or the 1st of june if you're in america
uh we will be doing a pc
building competition stream where we
will take it in turns to build the
ultimate
gaming pc from gigabyte who's been kind
enough to send us all the parts
so we'll see who can build the most
monster pc in
the time frame yeah that we have which
is unlimited whoever does it fastest
wins and whoever designs it nicely that
means wires
boys in the right places uh we'll also
get bonus points yes if you'd like to
catch that live and watch us make a
clown of ourselves then make sure to go
over to twitch.tv
trash taste links down in the
description below and we'll be streaming
that these times on screen right now
no doubt it'll be a very long stream
because we're [ __ ] everything up see
you then anyway the next category
actually hit it what is it
best complaining about america moments
you mean the entire world
well when did this start to become a
thing i can't
i don't know i think i started casually
complaining about america and we all
joined yeah what was the first
complaining about america i remember
what started this and then just like
there's so many differences
i i feel like this wasn't a thing at the
beginning of the podcast and then
something happened and then like the
floodgates just opened yeah
right like i can't remember i think it's
when our audience kind of caught on
being like these guys
love to complain about america for some
reason my jacket off for this one
this is a heated topic my favorite one
let's look at the nominees let's look at
the nominations
where are your shoes on the bench
i feel like we're gonna be like this for
every single one a
apparently it's so that you can wear
shoes on the bed
oh yeah oh i still feel that way you
know yeah i'm pretty sure that's what it
is ever since i found that out i just i
hate that thing now no i didn't mind it
i thought it looked nice but legit
everything ever since i found out about
that the first thing i do when i get to
a hotel
rip that [ __ ] off put in the corner
pretty sure it just breaks the [ __ ]
geneva convention right
like like how is this allowed like some
really important issues going on in the
world
and this should be up there like number
one this needs to be sorted out the
other one is american pint versus
british point play this is true
american pine's the biggest scam ever by
the way you guys got ripped off well i
don't know why
when americans took the pint from us for
some reason they made it smaller
this is true yeah why would they do this
and then everything else bigger
yeah the only thing that matters the
only thing that matters
a pint a point how do you [ __ ] that up
how do you [ __ ] that up america the only
thing where you actually care about your
cost
to quantity ratio yeah is when they're
like oh hold on a second
hold on let's make it smaller let's not
get too big it's like no no especially
when we're talking about american beers
as well you don't need
less american beers to get you drunk you
need more of it more of it
uh what's this third one america is
dangerous
yeah that's just the general statement
is that just a statement
i've never been to a motel so i don't
[ __ ] with those yeah because
that's why people die in films that's
why fugitives like hide out
right every single thing that's bad
happens near a motel oh man i don't even
remember that episode i don't remember
that episode but i guess we'll talk
about how dangerous
american motel is yeah america is
dangerous i mean i've never stayed
at a motel before but i can just already
tell i mean everybody wants
to i want to simulate near death um so i
do want to say
i want to simulate my favorite quentin
tarantino movie had a motel let's see if
there's somebody like
changing identities in the room next
year yeah yeah and blowing up their car
i've actually stayed in a motel before
really yeah i felt sketch as [ __ ] yeah
right
because i i remember like the first time
i take stay the motel was like before ax
and i remember getting to the parking
lot and i'm just like there's at least
like been five people who've been shot
here
i feel like oh my god i feel like
there's someone doing [ __ ] heroin
around the corner or something
it felt sketchy to be fair you could say
that about any street corner in l.a
i'm sorry it was my first time i like
you america yeah come on i love you too
but come on now uh american food is
disgusting
play the club aki took me to a steak and
shake once which is where like
the optimal place of where you do that
and i just saw like six americans
dipping their fries
into their shakes i'm just like i can't
i can't be here yeah i no i couldn't
it literally ruined my steak and shaky
experience my official reaction there is
interesting because i'm not really that
against it right
i i don't i don't hate it i've done it
before i thought it was okay i
understand
the flavors why you'd want to do that
you're [ __ ] facey i guess yeah i know
what my face is
yeah i mean this one i mean the thing
about american food is that i don't
actually think american food is
disgusting
do you throw one or a ten yeah one or
two yeah they
absolutely nail it and they have the
best food on earth yeah or they have
like white castle
yeah yeah it's either five guys a white
castle yeah top or the bottom it's it's
like you
you either you either way you destroy
your body but is it like is it does it
feel good or does
it feel bad yeah yeah it's
it's like the you know the uh what was
the show that did like the crazy hot
scale
oh yeah yeah both like uh was it like
that's the show [ __ ] i i forgot the
name of the show
i know what you're talking about i had
an analogy there then i completely lost
it
uh and then the last one is americans
are a different species of human
strength what is this clip
i love americans but there's just like
just general life stuff yeah
what what every time i go to america i'm
like this is another planet
like i i can't relate to these
well that's obviously a bit of an over
exaggeration i cannot relate to a lot of
americans
there's just some things where i'm just
like i can't believe this is a thing
i can't i can't remember what we
complained about you know i can't relate
to them at all
i feel like americans are very just uh
you know out there in a good way most of
the time
i really appreciate how open americans
are
sometimes you just wish they weren't
though um but i mean that's with anyone
right yeah yeah i'm sure people wish
that i would shut the [ __ ] up for 10
minutes
yeah but um man i mean i i feel like the
reason we love complaining about
americans is because
we hang out with a lot of americans yeah
we're right i mean
i'm dating americans this is the thing
as well where people are like man you
know nothing about american culture i'm
like man you really don't realize how
outside america works do you yeah
literally all we get is your [ __ ]
leftovers that's like
your leftover movies your leftover tv
yeah yeah
unfortunately i do know how it works
it's until you see yourself in the third
person that you realize
wow yeah we're weird like like out of
all these
hearing all of them again i'm just like
wearing shoes on bed yeah i'd say
wearing shoes on
because like um i think like most of
these i just like you know some of them
are annoying some of them are offensive
whatever to me i think this one offended
my entire generation
like my [ __ ] my [ __ ] ancestors are
like turning in their [ __ ] graves
right now hearing this opinion every
asians just pulling their hairs out
right now
yeah it's true yeah honestly yeah yeah
we
we kind of grouped i remember i remember
like we grouped out
like the entire western world and like
the europeans are like no this ain't our
mans
you know i don't do that in the uk some
households in the uk do that and that's
how you know they're the weird kid yeah
yeah um i i am curious because i feel
like most people voting on this are
gonna be american
yeah right yeah i didn't realize
i never thought about that i to enjoy to
see what the americans yourself chose is
the best american let's find
out all right all right as the one who
apparently complains about america
yeah i'm very honest go on to read out
this award
oh this might surprise you okay well
which one do you think it is it's
i'll give you a clue it's not it's not
the first one really yeah it's not the
first one which one do you think it is
americans are a different species of
human but the nail in the head gone
wow a different species
wow what's the percentage can we get the
breakdown
i was not expecting that forty one point
nine percent fourteen
one point nine percent of the votes
what's the second one wearing shoes on
your bed
good good good three that should have
won
the thing is that we think that's just
absolutely vital
to every american voting on it they're
just like a lot of them don't think of
it as a big deal yeah
i mean fair enough you know fair enough
hopefully we have opened your eyes just
a little bit
honestly that's more opia for them they
can never take their shoes off
i guess but everyone around them is
going to be grossed out yeah so i'm
pretty sure like humanity regresses
every time someone doesn't take their
shoes off when they get on the bench i
remember i hate to call rustage out like
this but
rustage when he came to my house in
japan did that he you know because in
japan you have the what is it
and i was like yeah this is my house and
i'm sure i'm like this is the because
the bathroom's right next to the front
right oh cool starts walking in with the
shoes on
dirty into my i'm like
for us it's not too late to seek help
you can change your others i i can
change sorry i i know you said i forgive
you
yeah now you know for next time all
right next next category next category
best best meme this is gonna be a
contested category
this is so [ __ ] the subreddit was
just [ __ ] came out like all right let
me let me see what we got
there is countless yeah so many i don't
even think five or six nominations or
whatever can do this just yeah i'm
pretty sure like going through this is
like when humanity first discovered oil
you know it's just a [ __ ] gold mine
right
you can't lose what are we doing
with it all right let's find out what
the nominations are
born we got four oh there's only four
okay so we got
one or three oh this is one of three
okay
that's what i like to hear very nice all
right so the first one is
bottom gear which we'll have we'll have
the full screen version yeah yeah
we've got
the driftwood i remember the watching
the drift one was just like
like we got on r slash all for this meme
yeah yeah yeah
and that's how you know it was a good
meme right he's made it on every song
because this was the only
meme as well oh yeah that's right i
think this is the only meme out of
all of these that didn't wasn't actually
upvoted on our own subreddit but just
got spread around
every other subreddit i love this one
though the before and after the entire
episode
i mean this is just the culmination of
the best screencasts yeah right
it's just me made in here yeah all right
let's look at the next page
uh don't quote us quotes uh
ladybird man hug oh yeah i like that
meme i like that i mean
connor i love this kind of reaction did
you do this on purpose do you remember
doing this
i didn't even remember the context i
don't remember like what did reynolds
say that major something weird and i was
like yeah
[Laughter]
and then we go i love this one the god's
middle finger one the middle finger one
yeah
that one is so good i mentioned earlier
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that was like a good
out of context
uh screenshot and also a good meme yeah
yeah yeah
and the last page
i'm surprised i'm surprised this clip
didn't come out to like like come out on
like the best
out of context clip yeah your finger
have you ever fingered yourself and i
remember being like what and then you're
like oh me neither
weird question i [ __ ] love this
this is such a multi-layered that's so
multi-layered that's like you have to be
integrated into the trash tastes like
together you need to understand the law
yeah yeah and then the american dress it
was just a fantastic edit fantastic
it's such a good idea and then this is a
very recent meme which is really a trash
taster
how like wide the trash taste law goes
yeah that uh this counts as like a trash
taste
even though it's something like
something i would say is like in the
extended trash taste cinematic universe
i would say
that that's that goes there your
favorite meme oh
man i don't know if i have a favorite
meme because all all of these memes are
like we go back to the first one i would
probably have to say the watching the
drift me
just because there were so many
iterations of it and it made its rounds
so far i do like the bottom gear one
bottom gear one is one gear one i really
do like i [ __ ] love that one that's
just a good mate
that's just a good pick of like three
mates yeah yeah yeah yeah it could go on
my wall when i'm like
80. yeah i remember that me and the boys
you know
i love that one that was great i think i
don't know this is this is different
this is difficult this is
really hard i also love the [ __ ] i
mean this is just best screenshots
yeah um i love the american trash taste
because i i feel like that just like
epitomizes trash tastes like
single-handedly motivated me to not get
fat
i was like if i'm gonna look like this i
am [ __ ]
not gonna get to this point how health
this coming after the complaining about
america moment category it's beautiful
it's just beautiful right it's such a
beautiful place to see
the order yeah yeah
[Music]
what do you guys think let's say one you
gotta say one
night honestly i think i'm here mates i
think it's gonna be
the quotes of us three quotes all right
all quotes all right let's find out
everywhere
all right trash taste the water with
best meme goes to
the quote collage
wow i mean i it this did make the rounds
so
trio i'll read mine if everybody is rich
then nobody is
broke i remember you saying that i
remember saying this one
and i was immediately one of those
things i was like i hope no one noticed
how stupid that thing i said was i meant
to say something else
but i just said that i totally did not
mean to say that but it came out and i
was like no one's going to notice this
people notice and then my one is uh
young people are young dumb and full of
calm
that's not even that shouldn't even be
attributed to me because my dad used to
say that
and then yours is if you set your mind
to it you can jack off to anything is
this from trash taste i don't think this
is yours
from my own channel yeah i can't
remember which video it was but what
were the percentages ashley
yeah what was the percentage uh the
winner was the winner with 19.99
yeah what was second place second place
was uh
conor as the [ __ ] t-rex oh percentage
is
that was like a perfect combination of
two different meals
that's
point five percent was bottom givings
bottom gear mates ah i wish that was a
little bit higher
i do wish that was a little bit higher
ten point two percent one is
god's middle finger oh the screenshot oh
which one came last yeah the one that
came last was number six
which is uh ladybird's mad hug
oh yeah okay okay i mean
episode i think the one where he like
leans into my mic was a better yeah yeah
yeah personally but
i mean yeah well deserved i guess what
is up those were
so many good memes subreddit doing its
work yeah i hope you guys continue to do
your work yep
all right what's the next one let's look
at the next category what is the next
category
best best tangent this whole podcast is
a tangent damn straight i don't know how
we like narrowed this one down
because i think i feel like the entire
podcast is every moment of it every
moment it's just a tangent this one was
based on
the severity of the tension yeah how far
it went yeah how far just
based off how strongly people will
remember this one yeah because it was so
recent i remember this and and when when
it came out when it came up we all were
like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah like so i could just on that i
could see this okay play the clip
i have so my shower
what curtain going on what is actually
going on
i love the like just half a second pause
of just our brains processing what he
just said
the challenge came out of nowhere
absolutely out of nowhere i don't think
i've ever felt physical whiplash from a
conversation until
until like i was on a podcast with
ladies that's true that's true like
like you know you're like compared to
the drifting episode where we were like
[ __ ]
feeling the g's turning the corner yeah
now the ladybit episode was like
i felt more g's having a conversation
with ladybird
than i did ever did during the drifting
episode man and then the second one is
talking about poop i mean this could be
anything
it could be any of them play the clip
why do we talk about [ __ ] as
like every time we stop don't don't
[Laughter]
i think it's supposed to symbolize as
going off yeah
yeah yeah yeah this isn't like the clip
but it's kind of like symbolizing yeah i
mean i mean i mean
it's just like a theme where just like
whenever we talk about poop it is a big
tangent yeah chris hijacks a yacht
i remember this one i remember this one
i got really drunk and early hijacked a
boat with my estonian friend in london
wait wait wait wait wait you can't just
say that i can't go into detail
no wait come on i love how he couldn't
even like talk about it
he's just like imma just drop this
bombshell and see you later
i remember there was like a few stories
that chris told on that podcast we were
just like out of nowhere
like how he's like served elon musk or
something like that oh yeah
yeah yeah like a castle right yeah
that's right i remember that exact
moment because because like i dropped i
was opening a bottle of wine
and i dropped the wine bottle bottle
opener with such disgust
that he hadn't told me about this before
why chris thank god i'm talking about
saver phase zero watch
watch unlimited blade works and then
that's that's like the main line
timeline so you can enjoy
heaven's feel and then if you want to
enjoy more of the fake franchise you can
because none of it's technically canon
this is the only episode where i was
like when are they gonna stop
because it was it was mostly it turned
into mostly a fate episode yeah
even though we didn't plan it at all and
uh that started completely just from a
tangent
and then that's turned into like a 17 to
20 minute tangent yeah yeah yeah
that's uh kind of like rotted your mind
i think i think i was i was actually i'd
never wanted like to stop recording be
like can we
can we change this we've never done that
before i've never we've never asked to
like move on
yeah but that was the one time i'm like
i'm gonna do it yeah i'm gonna ask
luckily i'm gonna say it stop
just generally going on tangents play
the clip
the way i talk about americans is like
the way i like like to [ __ ] on my
cousins you know what i mean
it's it's like the distant cousin that i
just like to talk [ __ ] about we don't
hate on america we just like making fun
of america
i love how that sentence alone could
have been so out of context yeah i love
talking about americans like i like
[ __ ] on my cousin just
stop the sentence there you have this
one yeah i got this one i mean
for this one host biased ladybird shower
curtain
uh i think that was the tangent that
sticks out to me the most oh that's 100
i think trash taste is like i mean we
talk we tangent about poop
and tangent about america all the time
they're just not like
strong enough in our yeah in the memory
of an iconic
in terms of the biggest whiplash uh
ladybird number one i say chris hijacks
a yacht number because like
like the shower curtain moment was like
a build up of about 15 more tangents
that we were like
building on to seem like the dumbest of
all yeah
i've never heard a sentence that started
with so much
so the best tangent goes to
the ladybird shower curtain surprisingly
[Music]
yeah what was the percentage for this
one this this should have been one of
the biggest ones yeah probably
29.4 20. that much so much 29.4
second place was chris hijacking a yacht
with 22 points chris hijacking
okay yeah as i said yeah those are
definitely the biggest ones well good
well done ladybird that's right
you've won so yeah biggest tangent and
biggest chat goes to you
what is the next category try
special moment oh okay so i mean this is
going to be pretty uh
narrowed down i guess because there's
only been three especially uh
originally we had best trash taste
special and then we kind of realized
there's only three specials there's not
really much to choose from
so let's narrow it down to the best
moments you enjoyed from the trash taste
specials all right let's look at the
nominees so what are the nominees
two cars of course
eventually though i might have done a
small oopsie
your [ __ ] face is priceless because i
heard the [ __ ] clutch
i heard it from all
my favorite shot of this is when you
were just like i bet god's giggling away
at his car and i'm just [ __ ] losing
it in my own car
i know you too wow
you break it and i just i just i just
couldn't contain myself
i thought it was i thought it was like
the most on-brand kind of thing that
could ever happen what can i say monkey
brain breaking
and then i was like all right we got the
dub and then connor's like finna break
another one
yeah yeah honestly and then next one is
god wins the chess tournament arc oh man
this was
i can't re-watch this was the biggest
upset it wasn't to play the clip play
the clip
look at your face look at your face man
you were like nothing what an amazing
moment what an amazing w that was
probably like top five best moments of
my life
never threw so hard in my life you know
i just played [ __ ]
that was like this this wasn't so much
funny as much as it was just like
you couldn't script this right if like
i'm i'm surprised how
well the trash taste tournament arc was
just like came out
like like it was like an anime script
yeah honestly you know
like all three of us got top three you
know even though it's the most proud
third place i've ever taken in my life
and like
biggest plot twist of the entire arc
which is
me coming out on top it's the
protagonist pals man that's another
piece of the lord
the protagonist the protagonist we have
the protagonist we have the antagonist
how do you feel about this connor not
good i'm good all right well this next
one is probably my favorite
gone cycling meltdown play the club you
know what the [ __ ] lifting off things i
like
how about listening off things i hate
joey
for being an australian [ __ ] who's
[ __ ] ahead of me right
now i love the classical music in the
background it's so very good it's very
fitting i'm just like
this moment would have wouldn't have
worked so well if you didn't film
yourself eating the ice cream
honestly a hundred percent coincidence i
didn't even know it was recording
we never turned the cameras off that's
what i never tell the camera's off
exactly honestly i think what this like
this was the most british moment of my
life
um i don't think like i i don't think
because
i don't think i've complained about
things more in my life than like this
exact moment because
yeah definitely this i was just dying by
this point i just i just needed to let
out some complaints man sorry
it got you through man it got me through
it got me through and then next one is
almost dying in the backseat of a drift
car to this day this is still this was
still terrifying
i love you guys
i just the g's felt insane yeah insanity
i just i still remember his like
maniacal laughs yeah he was i wish that
would got picked up more
like yeah i kept [ __ ] laughing like
he'd be like drifting around the corner
pumping this handbrake and looking at it
i've never seen anyone move a handbrake
like this in my life like the adrenaline
rush
it's not anything that i could ever
describe yeah right because
the adrenaline rush for that was by far
the biggest adrenaline rush i've felt in
my entire life
i can see how people get addicted to
adrenaline after doing that oh yeah i
wish i could drive that good
yeah right and said i break the calls i
was like is this handbrake even working
you're like moving it around so much
like
probably not doing anything in the final
moment the boys cheated cycling
my favorite those boys not me by the way
hey connor bye
hey connor oh are you there
you're [ __ ] oh it's so funny
all right let's find out the winner
though honestly [ __ ] man any of these
could win
honestly great moments just reliving
these moments it's just we
i like what i love about the specials is
that i have a [ __ ] great time
yeah filming the specials you know and
it's a fantastic like trip down memory
lane right like this doesn't feel like
six months ago i thought the drifting
almost difficult
to film i was like that was hard to film
and then yeah the cycling i'm like oh no
this is hot oh yeah yeah it's hard
i'm surprised how well the cycling
moment came out which like
[ __ ] mvp of the cycling special muda
and going through
100 hours of footage like 100 hours of
footage here like
six like eight cameras six gopros which
were constantly filming yeah we did us
went hey move on here's 100 hours of
footage
turned it into one yeah it was like half
a terabyte video yeah
it was it was a lot it was a lot and
there's audio and stuff it was
absolutely yeah
mvp mood on yeah but there can only be
one winner unfortunately
who do you want to win games oh [ __ ] me
these are all so good i
personally want god's cycling meltdown
win i think
because that just was hilarious i don't
know the editing was hilarious
i think you know objectively i enjoyed
the chess winning [ __ ] off moment
i'm not reading it that's just that's
just me i think um
my cycling meltdown is weird because
during filming i [ __ ] hated it but
like
it was it was just like the moment where
i look at it and i'm just like okay i'm
glad my suffering made for good content
yeah exactly
exactly but let's find out who's
suffering made for the best content
in this award oh it's upside down it's
like this okay
[Music]
it's gone cycling meltdown hey well
desert
walda's uh the worst
screenshots yeah i did i did
like my heart my heart skipped for a
second though i wanted to do a little
bait and switch
oh good honestly your meltdown is the
most iconic moment of the trash day
special
i would have to say it is the percentage
of votes that god got
yes got one with
uh hold on 28.5 percent 28.5 percent
that's pretty comfortable relatively
close yeah
what was second place second place was
gone winning the chess tournament with
24.6
wow that was close oh god that didn't
win
[ __ ] gone that's from last year christ i
mean
i mean yeah it's okay connor one one day
you'll have your time to shine
yeah hopefully next time well deserved
gone congratulations on your win yet
again
please maybe one day you'll win your own
trip please look forward to more trash
taste specials because they are on their
way
yeah win the next one and we'll get some
more fantastic moments from the specials
but
the next category ashley best drip even
goku doesn't look as good i
doubt that no one looks as good as drip
goku yeah what are the nominees
what the [ __ ] is this so we got ghance
steve [ __ ]
turtleneck of course of course we got
ladybird's outfit
uh i got my top hat that's not even drip
that's just like a piece of clothing
this trip that's true my berserk shirt
which is very i don't even remember that
episode
i think that that was because uh we
mentioned it yeah on the live stream
yeah and then connor's uh t-shirt that
you see him wear like five times the
emea show
one of one of the memes that didn't get
shown here which is connor and like
shiro emiya yeah which he wouldn't get
because he doesn't watch faye anyway
i've seen fate stay right unlimited
just name them all
you know what i mean if there's anything
i don't want to win it's my top hat
because that's not drip
that's literally just a hat i really
want the turtleneck to win i want the
turtleneck
i love how it's steve handjob's
turtleneck it's not gone it's not my
turtleneck
it's just the steve jobs it's the steve
[ __ ] turtleneck yeah well
you would think if steve hendricks won
the nickname category there might be a
bit of
yeah right a bit of a leaning towards
this i have a feeling
yeah um so let's find out here find out
let's find this category this strip
goes to steve [ __ ]
look how happy my boy is he knows he he
knows this i'm just gonna go and buy
as many turtlenecks oh yeah
what was the percentage ashley um got
one with 49.9
50
who came last was it joey's top hat no
joey's berserk [ __ ] oh okay
okay i mean yeah because that's just
that's shirt that's just normal
this is the shirt i'm just grasping at
straws for that fifth nomination yeah
yeah
all right what's the next category
actually laziest dress oh
[ __ ] this only has the one outfit in
their water so the laziest drip
to explain because it probably doesn't
make a whole lot of sense is the person
i think who wore the same amount of
shirts for the longest time right
yeah something like that but let's i
mean let's let's see let's
see i remember oh
wow we all walked through okay so
there's me connor and god but
wait didn't chris get nominated in this
originally
i swear he did in like like in in well i
remember when we got like the original
nominations yeah from like the survey
chris was on there for some reason
we had to remove him wait did he wear
the same show twice
i don't know where my trash taste
t-shirt is i've lost it really lost it
i don't know where it is i mean i
personally have worn this jujita shirt
many times on the podcast i've
worn that nerf shirt many times um i
thought it was okay to wear the trash
taste shirt multiple times yeah it was
wrapping you know
what the [ __ ] real winner of this is
the [ __ ]
um jojo shirt that we got from uh
they already got some good promotions
the amount of times
like collectively between the three of
us we've worn the glam jojo shirts
every episode secretly we're not
sponsored by glam by the way we just
love their show yeah exactly
um oh yeah fyi chris was on
the pole chris was on the pole okay wait
the wait for the for the votes
yeah why was he removed because he's
only been in two episodes
how many votes did he get well you'll
find out okay we'll find out we'll find
out okay so chris was on the original
poll
all right um i mean there's not much to
say um
i i feel like it might be i feel like
it's you yeah like it is you i think
it's me
always insulted by my t-shirt i feel
like i've seen your emea shirt about 10
times
i thought that [ __ ] it's nice i mean
it's it's like i
i can remember when you wear something
different because if it's not the emmy
shirt or one of like your drab kind of
like t-shirt colors
drab it's how dare you brown is
so one of the uh so one of the in one of
the netflix specials joey only bought
like one outfit or you didn't bring
enough outfits or something like that
and so he had to borrow connor's shirt
and of course it was just like a
dark red you could immediately tell it
was like the
color of drywall it's like yeah joey
walks in and i'm just like
joey this looks like the least joey
outfit i've ever seen i would never wear
this person
i need something to tone down my white
white white skin
just wear black i do but i like i like
how all the screenshots are awesome
there was a guy on reddit who actually
did the calculations and went through
every single episode he actually
quantifiably figured out who had the
laziest dream oh okay
the trash takes one runway this took way
too long it's not even funny looks like
a certain great crosstalk
actually counted every single shirt that
reappeared
and was worn twice so do we have the
results of this yeah the results of this
on the next page oh okay so let's have a
look at the
the results so scientifically speaking
connor had 29 unique outfits
so you wore the trash taste shirt four
times so you're repping in the shower
yeah yeah you're wrapping the shirt up
in the shirt the best but i wore two
episodes back to back as well i think
that was the two episodes we promoted it
probably yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think we all wore that episode but
uh this is the only page i have of the
trash
oh this is the only page uh i just
didn't include it once
oh okay i mean it doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if you want it yeah if you want to look
at the if you want to look at the full
thing then we'll leave the link to yeah
in the description i guess yeah shout
out to uh no peer 389 on the reddit you
didn't
you did god's work who was the winner
[Music]
[Laughter]
i have a feeling it's not connor oh it's
chris brown
you did it chris you did it chris you've
won an award you won an award for the
laziest trip
even though you've been on the show
twice what was the percentage
he won with 50. 50.8
50.
i want to see the other shirt he wore
like other than this one what was the
other shirt he wore the
navy blue color it was just yeah oh my
gosh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait so oh wait
who came uh second uh
yeah yeah yeah third was
with nine-point wow
this is hilarious best moment so far
chris congratulations you've won
congratulations you won the lazy strip
award congratulations congratulations
chris congratulations anytime we meet up
we'll we'll give you a
musical yeah i think i think we're
mocking chris that's why we put it in
we're like yeah
i think this is meant to be like a joke
nomination right yeah
yeah because the results are already
there right we already know quantifiably
well we know who is scientifically
proven to have the laziest trip but we
know who's the winner
yeah and we all feel that chris is the
laziest guy we know so
just it's just like you know you know
obviously everyone got the same feeling
just emanates lazy drip energy exactly
he's obviously come on chris you gotta
you gotta up your dreams
chris yeah but the next category what my
favorites actually
yeah the best trash taste animated oh
and god knows we've got way too many to
choose yeah we've got a lot of animators
there's a lot of really good channels of
them
honestly like i don't think anybody
expect the animations to be made
yeah we're so flattered and obviously we
are really so many other animations are
so good they're so good
fantastic so please keep them coming we
always share them on
our channel as well yeah but yeah let's
look at the nominations so we've got the
great burger debate uh
very very good just tons of clips some
some of the hardest parts were actually
picking
which video to put on this nomination
are these videos
yeah oh yeah no i just show the clip
yeah the best part
of a hamburger it's like the pizza thing
dude it's the simple energy
it's all the accumulation of the tastes
that come together
and they strike slightly moderately it
strikes slightly water
nice it's so good i love as well how he
makes all of us like
really look like how we are yeah yeah
it's so perfect
and then we have the uh just the kaiser
trash taste collection i was like
yeah i don't think we can play this
audio can we we can show some of this
yeah yeah
out loud now but in the video we have to
yeah we have to censor it unfortunately
[Music]
god the amount of references they were
able to cram in such a short
time span is like incredible in this one
honestly all of these honestly are just
crammed with references
yeah yeah i mean if we're talking about
references oh this one
this one is [ __ ] amazing i just
imagined you in the [ __ ] morning
every every morning
okay like in the mirror go you got you
got this kind of
you got it okay okay you [ __ ] got it
okay
so good it's so well so good absolutely
fantastic and then we got uh mori
calliope can't say the f word
this one made its rounds because of the
hololive subreddit yeah
i'll play the club sorry i really
shouldn't curse you you can call us
online
is it okay no he's totally good
i can't do it oh it's so good on the
rocks
this one is fantastic we're going to do
a scene with kermit
i didn't even get to say anything he's
[ __ ] laser beamed onto this car like
finally something i can fist i love that
one
honestly i can't even choose a favorite
i mean
we could only have five nominees for
this one but honestly every single
animator we've received has been
[ __ ] fantastic so please we really
love your work and we love watching them
as well
yeah absolutely but uh unfortunately as
with every award show there can only be
one winner
viewers the viewers get to vote their
choice yeah we'll see which one
is their favorite and honestly i have no
idea
i have a feeling which one might win but
we'll see okay
all right and the winner is oh
oh okay it's the jujutsu kaiser oh
okay okay okay okay wow in terms of like
animation this one is like
it's really i mean it's pretty the thing
that was cool about this one
was that it like the original ending for
jiu-jitsu guys in was like
original enough and they managed to get
the style down to a team
yeah and that's what i think that's what
impressed me the most out of this one
but honestly
they all impressed me yeah honestly
anyone like i feel like
out of like we it feels weird to have to
award
one of the winners because i just want
to give you all
everyone's a winner everyone's aware
everyone claps
but uh what were the percentages um 20
um this one was the one with the two
vote difference oh okay
oh this one was on with the two vote
difference okay so out of what 24
000 votes there's only one by two votes
oh my god wow
so what was the so what was the second
place the second one was maury glappy
oh i thought that one was gonna win yeah
that was a lot of views
yeah yeah yeah and then third fourth
fifth that was a great burger debate
with 22.99
yeah but uh if you guys uh want to
submit uh animations uh then just make
sure to title your videos trash tastes
animated so it's easier for us to find
and then yeah go ahead and animate any
moment on twitter yeah this actual
winner
i think it was like three weeks after it
was uploaded before either or
any one of us saw it right because
nobody saw it at all please at us on
twitter or
at least title it trash taste animator
so it's easy for us to find yeah but
yeah keep your animations coming we love
all of them
and the next category is ashley what is
it best rant best
rant oh god there's so many
so many this is this is just like ninety
percent of the possibilities it's like
this tangent right it's like
there's eight there could be like four
or five nominees from each other
when aren't we ranting about something
there are some standout rants i will say
this yeah
these are my favorites look at the
nominees the great burger debate i mean
we just saw the man in the motel animals
all right but let's see it in 4k yeah
hamburger is not a by itself
it's not a patty by itself you got like
potatoes you got vegetables
you know it's a good round when we're
just [ __ ] screaming from the get-go i
do not remember being that heated
what i i i couldn't shut you up
i remember you being heated because i
was laughing the entire time
this was obviously me running on pure
adrenaline and rage i think so
because i do not remember like i'm like
looking at this and i do not remember
saying the words that i did or being
that i've never seen you this is
everything
answer apology i do not remember the
words that i said i do not apologize
for judgments honestly i would give up
like if if i sound like this i'd give an
apology video i don't remember
it don't hate me i i don't get heated i
wasn't very much
this angry in my life i'm sorry i was
more angry here than i was breaking [ __ ]
in your videos
uh there are too many sabers in fate
we're just talking about the series we
haven't gotten into fate law
we're not getting into that yeah
i don't like all those spin-offs like
this is the moment
literally anything but this topic
anything please the next one is my
personal favorite
school days was the masterpiece of that
generation for episode three i believe
yeah yeah one of our early ones it's so
funny that you say like the school days
like mal is either like a ten or two
that's yeah i was definitely one of
those people who put it
i know you did your piece of [ __ ]
because because i know exactly what my
what is going on here
look how bare the studio was back now
yeah i think this is the first time we
ever got heated on the podcast yeah
didn't take us long three episodes what
were we doing for the first time
being civil were we civil in the first
two episodes i guess we were
um yeah i mean this this is a classic
moment for me this is something
yeah this is i'm still proud of this
moment this is uh still an awful opinion
awful it is awful it's terrible
despicable frankly um
and i don't know why he has a job
judging other people's mouth when this
exists yeah right
that's i'm clearly not fit for the job
uh next one is bowling is boring it is
dude this is
i was very passionate i still am very
passionate about this
play the clip bowling is like the most
depressing activity out of all of the
activities
really i think so i feel like bowling
with alcohol
is fun it's fine but bowling without
alcohol is
boring
god describes 95 of activity
why did you sound so unsure you're like
is it boring
i think because i just realized
i was just like talking [ __ ] you weren't
talking [ __ ]
it was it was like it was like yeah the
floor is made out of
i'm pretty sure i just i'm pretty sure i
just auto generated that sentence as
i was like moving my mouth that was like
text to speech
dumbest [ __ ] take it's always from a
[ __ ] dragon ball
or like someone who like just tweets
about dragon ball yeah
it still is true uh i think out of
everything this was
the most rantiest episode oh yes yeah
because we are like no no one was safe
not at that episode we were like if
we're gonna [ __ ] on one fan base we're
[ __ ] on everything we literally [ __ ]
on like every anime fan base that exists
if everyone is rich then nobody is broke
yeah exactly
exactly honestly that's my favorite that
was my favorite to film in terms of just
ranting about different things
i don't think that's gonna win i don't
think that's gonna win because i think
that's gonna win
i feel like that was just an entire
episode of ranting and
you couldn't like the dragon ball one
stood out the most but yeah
we could have we could have put any kind
of money genuinely believe the saber
one's gonna win
really i have a fight i feel the great
burger debate i have a feeling
everyone's gonna win either gonna be
great burger debate or school days
i i feel the great burger debate is
going to be powered by the mana motel
animated because that went
quite viral but there's only one way to
find out i guess
so let's do it trash taste awards best
rant goes to
the great burger debate
again not surprised though i mean it's
it's hard to
nail you down it's hard to nail down a
more
like one of like i mean there's so many
iconic clips right the great burger
debate
is an iconic clip for distractions
i like how whenev whenever like someone
outside of the podcast hangs out with us
they get surprised that we do the actual
the actual things that we say on the
podcast yeah they were like i thought
the hamburger
thing was a bit like you actually liked
it i remember
the first time like i remember the first
time we were interviewing ashley and we
were at the denny's and i ordered a
hamburger
gives me the most evil look and she's
like oh this was real
you guys actually do this [ __ ] we do we
do
this isn't just for entertainment i
remember like when ken came on as well
like uh we we went we went to like a uh
went to an italian restaurant
yeah and we ordered pizza i didn't eat
my crust
and he was like whoa and the ken's
producer was just like oh
this is this is a thing you you weren't
[ __ ] around it's a reference to trash
taste you like that guy from trash taste
right now
um the great burger debate won with 32.6
percent of the vote
um in second place was school days
oh of course yeah with 23 what came last
what came last was bowling is boring wow
fair enough it's probably not as
memorable as the other ones for sure
yeah well there you go yeah awesome not
surprising what's the next category
actually
catchphrase of the year oh my god i have
a feeling i i know what it's going to be
i know this one's i know which one let's
see the nominees let's see the nominees
it's different
i [ __ ] with this i'm proud of that one
uh x with attitude again this is
attributed to my dad not me
uh i worked at the bbc classic is that a
clown
is that a catchphrase or just or just a
thing that
and i say the the diamond in the rough
right here why are you laughing
i love that we have friends that
literally like like checked her and goes
to ghana's like god do you look at the
bbc
yeah everyone jokes to khan about
working at the
he says it's so [ __ ] much off camera
this is like the probably the biggest
in-joke within our like friend
yeah 100 uh in terms of the iconic
catchphrase i think this completely goes
down to like
how much it was memed and how often we
actually say it right
and i feel i mean it's it's different it
hits differently
i mean i know we say that a lot we
didn't invent them yeah we didn't invent
it
i would say the one that we say the most
that we invented was x with attitude
yeah yeah i mean i've like i've i think
i've been hanging out with joey too much
because i've started to say i [ __ ] with
this more often
i like it and like you know you know you
know that phrase that you start off
saying ironically because you want to
like
you want to like yeah you want to joke
around and then it turns into like oh
i'm just saying this all the time now
that's me with i [ __ ] with this what can
i say i'm a trendsetter
on that one oh my god i i mean
honestly i probably think it's going to
be it hits different i mean it hits
different but it's going to be
bittersweet
actually really really i think there
could be something else i'm i'm hoping
like
the black horse right here is the why
you're laughing i really like my
favorite yeah
i really hope this wins yeah so uh
okay the catchphrase of the year is
it hits different and here's different i
mean it do hit different thoughts
i feel like it's so generic and not we
didn't make it yeah right we didn't make
it that that one won
it's bittersweet it's bittersweet but we
appreciate you guys for all
that does that mean we have to come up
with a new catchphrase for next year
yeah every year we need a new
catchphrase yeah we need a new
catchphrase what was it percentages uh
it hit a different one with 49.7 [ __ ]
out
in class yeah not even close second
place in second place with 21.4 percent
of the vote is
why are you laughing me oh there yeah
oh man what was after that third place
was
uh i worked at the pvc
i got i got i've got to find somewhere
else to work so i can
start a new catchphrase i apologize the
third place was with attitude
oh okay that makes more sense that makes
more sense
because yeah i mean i i i'd say that
makes sense
i'm a bit disappointed but it makes
sense yeah yeah yeah all right let's
look at the next category next
is guest of the year now we've had a lot
of guests on trash
this year all of them are right chris is
about to follow up
with this chris has one phone it's
really the whole episode
since when
you know it's obviously not uh uh you
know the nicest thing to rank
your guests in order yeah but our hearts
and everyone's hearts
everyone's a number one yeah we just
wanted to see which ones uh you guys
like the most actually i think we're
just curious
and yeah you know we're very grateful
for all the guests that we've had on
yeah absolutely um you know
i i guess this is less to like rank
everyone and more of just like awarding
you know awarding someone who really
left an impression on the viewers
and that's right and that's how i see it
yeah absolutely so uh
we haven't had a bad guess absolutely
not everyone's been except for yes
well let's look at the nominees just to
refresh our minds on who we've had this
year
jesus christ she's gonna [ __ ] hate me
chris is going to kill you ashley
ashley you're gonna you're really gonna
do a boy like this
so for context this is from the webtoon
that someone is making of us
and they decided to make chris into this
like ball of lard for some reason
that's the only way to describe it
really
and uh yeah ashley was like that's
that's a perfect picture of chris
chris came on episode five episode 30.
yeah yeah so he's the only one who's had
two
yeah and then we have the lovely shibuya
kaho yeah and then we have melanie
obviously remember being a guest on here
melin
melin tries to forget it every day and
then we have the queen of degeneracy
herself sit snap come on
and then we have of course more climbing
who couldn't forget
noriaro alexi uh we had ken
wonderfully talented kenata wonderfully
talented nano as well
and we had aki come on ladybeard and
last but not least reyna scully we've
had a lot of guests on i did not expect
ourselves so many guests once i started
this
ten guests well yeah i think because you
know because the borders haven't been
open we haven't really been able to get
a lot of international guests on it's
been fun
we got as many as we did yeah honestly
because i thought with
you know the world situation being the
way it was that we would be really
really limited with the guests that we
could find
yeah because what is that one every one
out of five episodes was a guesstimation
yeah that means
and you know people always uh you know
those complaining being like oh you
should just wave the rule for xxx
situations yeah
no it's like i don't know i think to us
it's like the the
the importance of trash taste is getting
to be with air in person
and the chemistry and also getting to
meet with them before yeah getting hang
out with them afterwards
you know making sure that it's not just
uh come on my show [ __ ] off you know
come hang out with us because it's like
every single guest we've had we've
really had like a proper like connection
yeah after their episode has aired and
like i hope that conveys to
the audience as well because one of the
biggest things that before we decided to
have guests on is that we didn't want to
just
interview our guests we wanted the
guests to be you know part of part of
the roundtable
and there's nothing there's nothing
better than an in-person interaction
yeah in my opinion
part of my favorite part of having a
guest on isn't just the recording the
episode it's just hanging out afterwards
we just enjoy we just enjoy hanging out
and meeting people chris getting us
violently drunk
the normal stuff that happens when you
have chris of course but everyone has
been fantastic but of course they can
only be one winner
let's find out who the viewers voted for
yeah
i'm i'm curious if it'll be a
correlation of views on the episode
yeah be interesting let's find out we'll
see what the guess is
it was pretty [ __ ] ridiculous wasn't
it he won with 37.2 percent that's quite
a lot that's
pretty high there's ten nominees i can't
believe chris [ __ ] won
that means chris has won best kissed and
laziest trip
and biggest uh no ira's biggest clown i
wish he was chris he was
he was the greatest guest but god damn
was his other game
maybe chris will be in and running for
biggest clown next year
next episode chris is going to [ __ ]
rock up suit
blazer yeah i hope he does
just whenever chris is next on yeah yeah
but he inevitably comes on
i'm sure he will when he comes to when
he inevitably comes on again we don't
have a choice he just turns up
a tuesday he just turns what's going on
lads think that was the last recording
right he just texted us one day and he's
like
lads recording recording yeah recording
yes i guess so
all right i loved how he was like i
didn't know people were going to watch
this podcast when i first came on
so i didn't care i think that's why he
won lazier's trip
because he turns up in a shirt the
second time give a [ __ ] he was like no
one's going to watch trash tape
this is good this is this trash this
podcast is going to go down after three
episodes it's fine
no no he's like please let me back off
now chris look at us now
yeah well i understand why you know i
think his chris fits in so well
yeah it's it's understandable it's
nothing about chris yeah yeah yeah i
thought that we're giving him [ __ ] now
you know just uh guess shows i'm sure
i'm sure he'll give a [ __ ]
but again please go and watch every
single guest episode that we've had on
every single guest been [ __ ] amazing
so
shout out to you guys for helping us
make the show better yeah thank you i
mean
i thank you to everyone who came on we
had a [ __ ] fantastic time in
every episode that we filmed so far and
anyone we'd love to have you on again
hopefully uh we can add to this wall
this year as well
i'm sorry the new wall yeah i hope this
doesn't give the impression that we can
only
reinvite chris yeah anyone anyone is
welcome to become anyone
welcome to come exactly let's look at
the next category best argument
what i mean we've probably had about 50
arguments just in this episode
like the most heated argument or like
the most memorable
i wonder what the viewers of choosing
basically yeah right because if it's
like
strictly speaking the most argument
argument it's got to be the gacha thing
right
oh yeah that was by far the biggest guy
yeah yeah i think we had that
probably actually an argument yeah
but i'll just let's look at the nominees
for this oh yeah
play the clip you haven't joined the
gadget community unless you [ __ ]
gather
a thousand bucks and haven't got the one
with thick thighs you forget about three
months later [ __ ]
that's true it's true it is true and
then we got the hamburger
again we've gone over this one uh the
crosstalk no cross we've obviously gone
over
this clown clown uh and then bearded or
no
i forgot about this one you play the
crushed one sometimes it just crumbles
apart without the crust it's like the
integrity of this
sandwich has been ruined it's it's been
optimized it has not been
you cut off all the useless pieces
although
[Laughter]
although and then this is where it
started
moments before a disaster at the bidet
club
not realizing day or november i don't
want a wet [ __ ] ass
you don't have to be wipe that's what
toilet paper was invented
then i don't want wet [ __ ] fingers
after i wipe that's just
how [ __ ] weird
i still revisit this to this day because
she's so funny
i just can't believe this man doesn't
utilize the bidet just the lack of logic
in this argument
i mean the thing the thing about the
bidets is i still stand by heated toilet
seats
but today i'm still just like if if the
toilet paper i got here wasn't
so [ __ ] thin and break so easily then
i would use the bidet more often but
it's it's the wiping afterwards that
gets me mad it's the wiping afterwards
i used a clown gun were you always this
much of a clown
i'm sorry who won biggest clown connor
i'm sorry there you go
justly so i can't say anything i would
like to believe that that is more clown
[ __ ]
we have an uno reverse card ready at all
times now
what do you think's going to win this
one boys oh god i mean any of these
could honestly win
uh [ __ ] man i mean i have no idea
this is one of the most iconic things in
trash taste which is our argument
and i feel like i feel like the gacha
one is just such an intense argument
yeah yeah it's got to be the most
memorable surely even out of those
if you think i mean
it's literally the great burger debate
yeah not an argument
you know what i mean like the gangster
wanted something [ __ ] argument
i i would say the great burger debate
was like more heated
um the crust one was pretty heated as
well yeah um the gacha one
i don't know like i you guys should
watch the bidet one because that got
[ __ ] heated
i think he did this one again yeah i
can't remember exactly it got pretty
[ __ ] heated
with the gacha one the one sticks in my
head so much i don't know why yeah
honestly like
i mean i look at all these and out of
all them the gacha one sticks out is the
one where i'm just like
yeah i i don't really like agree with
what i said on that one yeah
i'll i'll backpedal yeah everyone had
some pretty [ __ ] takes on that one but i
guess that's what made it interesting
but yeah again they can only be one
winner it's a gone it's useless oh it's
me
is it on you it's you i think right is
it no oh
never mind all right here we go best
argument for trash days award-winner
is gotcha's gambling ah
okay that you know what makes sense
i think it was by far the one that made
the viewers be like are they okay
yeah are they gonna be okay after this
argument watching a friendship
that wasn't the case there was you know
all the other ones i know
you funny but that was the one where we
got so many comments people like oh god
yeah okay we were okay don't worry
we are still friends we're all great
because i commented to be like guys guys
seriously it's chill yeah
don't worry it's like it's fine we were
just in it
yeah what was the percentages on that uh
gambling one with 36.2 percent of them
36.2 percent
in second place was the state debate
with 24.4
okay oh okay cross came
i feel like they came last because not
many not enough people have the
experience
yeah to have them true true true i
personally advocate for the bidet clip
though it's so funny
it is a good place it's so funny yeah
all right what's the next category
actually
best trash taste special oh i guess we
did leave this one in i thought we'd cut
this one out but i guess we didn't look
in the trash
but uh i guess they left it in there's
only three oh god don't you look like a
clown right now huh
now we're already looking forward look
at this try harder
it's the new season now gone this counts
as the next year you can already be
nominated
get nominations early guys i guess uh
there's only three nominees for this one
uh but let's let's check it out i am
actually curious to see which one people
like the most
yeah i would say because people voting
on this must be i would say the the more
uh like dedicated trash taste fans oh
yeah yeah
like the casual one so mean i'm curious
to see which ones are
they'll pick so we obviously that our
first one was the
chess tournament off yeah chestnut which
was uh insane
then we got the trash taste uh real
tokyo drifting
and then the cycling across japan
special i like
all of these for their own reasons yeah
i i think that
the best story is the chess one 100 i
think the most fun
to film with the drifting yeah and then
i think the cycling one showcases our
chemistry
i feel cycling we definitely like
perfected like yeah
we learn a lot from the drifting special
we do and uh like
i don't know if we've already mentioned
this but by far the best thing about
this was having the walkie-talkies
imagine how boring this would have been
if we didn't have the walkie-talkies
um i feel like the the drifting one to
me was a proof of concept to be like
okay trash taste is cool
can we take this outside and bring the
same chemistry yeah i also think that
the thumbnail is like the best one i i
made that thumbnail
i love it it's so good they're all great
thumbnails honestly and they're all
great videos but uh yeah this
i mean this one you like like we've
already said i i'm
i'm like surprised how much the stars
aligned for this one this one was a real
style
um this one i mean i love all of them
yeah they're all great and there are a
lot of people who watch the trash taste
podcast
don't watch the specials please do
please just consider watching we put so
much work into this and it's fully
backed by the patrons
yeah it's that really fully done like
honestly we try to get it as close to
like
tv quality honestly i think the biggest
thing is we try to get it as close to tv
quality
without having a tv crew behind us just
a couple of cameramen that's all you do
not know
the [ __ ] logistics that went into
filming this one oh
my god we had to bust out the blueprints
for that one ellie was lucky that she
didn't have to help with that one yeah
she would have lost her mind really
hello yeah uh but i guess without
further ado
let's uh find out there is only one
winner there is only one
and the best trash taste special of the
year goes
to yeah the cycling special yeah
i'm not i'm not i'm not surprised well
yeah if i had to if i was a betting man
i would put cycling drifting chests
would be the order yeah is it cycling
drifting chess
it is cycling yeah yeah what is the
percentage
cycling one with 60.1 percent wow
that's the biggest margin we've had 60.1
i mean i i was like i was honestly
surprised because after the drifting
special i was like this is our magnum
opus
i don't think we can top this i don't
know man because it took us like what
15 drafts to get something that was good
like we had so many drafts that sucked
and i was like oh god is this video just
bad
yeah we [ __ ] because i knew when we
were filming i think
when we switch off the cameras i knew we
would film the banger yeah
but then like it what i didn't realize
was how much
of the editing we would have to put into
it to like convey the feeling that i
felt when i was filming a big big shout
out to muna and once again man like he
[ __ ] brought this video honestly um
mvp of the specials not us
honestly we just we just show up and we
just do random [ __ ]
i wouldn't say that man there's a lot of
planning that we had to do it was
[ __ ] hell
our bikes were a monstrosity of cables
and batteries
all the cameramen that helped us out as
well the amount of times i had to
re-watch the cycling special to like
create a coherent narrative out of this
because
because it was just like so all that
like the first draft was so
all over the place and trying to like
weave that into something that you guys
could follow
um was probably the biggest challenge
i've had all year actually all right
let's find out what the next category is
best trash taste moment in general let's
have a look at the nominees
of the best trash taste moment god
there's so many to choose from oh this
is this is when this is when it gets
really really [ __ ] hard i like um i
love how the first two are from the the
hands of most of these we don't actually
need to play because you've already yeah
we've already i mean i i feel like when
when we made this this was just like
the highlight reel of some of the best
moments that had got nominated
from other categories so we obviously we
got the korean or
uh gangbang debate conor mother knows
breast debate rare soul carrying guns
figure challenge win the great burger
debate
uh page two uh me coming out
mailings three by three and the bidet
debate that revolves at the time bidet
debate
i don't even know honestly i i i'm
biased mother knows breast has a special
place in my heart yeah honestly any of
these could win man i
it's like picking between your children
um the it's this is way too hard for me
there's so many iconic moments
that have happened throughout the year
and none of these were planned
yeah they just like i i'd say the only
one out of all these that we knew
was coming was the kuru or gangbang
debate because i knew because
we were we planned that i knew i knew we
were going to lose our [ __ ] minds
over that
and we did yeah and it turned down to a
great like it was it was one of the
moments where i knew something was going
to happen and i'm glad that it kind of
lived up to what was going to happen in
my mind definitely
um oh god i guess there's only one way
to find out really
let's just should we just start this all
right i really don't know this is one of
the biggest awards
the viewers decided for the best trash
taste moment of uh i guess
2020 season 20 season 1 21
i guess season 1 season 1 just keep it
simple keep it simple the best moment of
season 1 of trash taste
is create creative drumroll in post
mudan it is
oh it's upside down
what is it moonlight finding nemo
the best trash taste moment of the year
season one
is connor's mother nose restaurant
[Music]
wow really wow i'm not surprised because
that is the one that to this day i still
get people
talking to me about it people to me
about mother nose breasts that
and i feel like it's such a visceral
eclipse
it's such a it's like oh god that's not
a clip you can share with the family no
no no no no no
yeah i mean i'm not surprised that one
morning
when they all played i'm like yeah i
think this one's gonna yeah because all
the other ones are good don't get me
wrong but yeah
they'll give you a reaction at least
from the viewers perspective what was
the percentage on this one
this one one with 19.8 oh it's closed
19.8
wonder if that'll be available little
hint as to what might be the best
episode yeah
i don't know people clearly like the
hentai yeah wow what came third
third was joey's coming out moment wow
what an amazing moment
i'm glad i did yeah yeah wow all right
and uh last but not least we have one
more category left but before before we
get into that
before we get into that we have to give
some shout outs to
you guys yeah uh and that's uh all the
people who sent us fan edits and fan art
because
the subreddit and the twitter wouldn't
be where it is without you guys
and there have been some [ __ ] amazing
fan edits and fan art that we've
received
this is just like a tiny amount that
ashley found in 10 minutes
yeah honestly this is just this is just
ashley
next slide please
this is just like a really really tiny
portion
yeah of the fan edits and fan art fan
everything though
place them on screen right now while
we're here
here's a highlight reel of everything
that came out yeah yeah while we talk
about fan art and how good it is and
thank you so much and
and we we couldn't choose just one
because there was just so many and
they're all just amazing in different
ways and we really really are like
grateful we're always like whenever we
hang out or we're
just chatting we're like yo you see this
piece of sick fan art yeah you send it
to each other so
again we all really really we really do
appreciate it yeah and uh
i do have a surprise for you boys oh
[ __ ]
uh do you do you want to bring it out
melin what what is it
i'm scared so i you know it would it
wouldn't feel
it wouldn't what the [ __ ] is what the
[ __ ] is that am i coming out okay
okay ashley i get i guess you'll bring
it out ashley's better dress
just give it to god give it to me what
the [ __ ] is this what is this
so like it wouldn't feel right having
the viewers you know having to like
narrow down
all of the fan edits and fan art that we
got okay um
but i felt like the fairest way was just
to look on reddit
right and see what was what did what did
the community
vote as like the one that was like most
memorable yeah it was like the top voted
fan uh fan arts
and so i got it framed for you boys
so this was unfortunately this was
second
just behind my laughing at corona
moments
on our subreddit but this was the
highest rated
fan edit stuff this year i remember when
i
spoke with this in my meme review video
i was like look at the god's head
god dance because because i'm the only
one in this picture
who is actually me
that's like some thanos hands this is
like pro gamer hands man
this is a pro gamer picture this is the
i i do love this place oh my god
i guess from this point onwards every
year we're gonna be framing the highest
yeah the highest
i mean i guess i wanted to surprise you
boys like awesome i feel like since
we're moving
studios soon yeah i wanted to have
something
for us to remember season one bye so
cool and uh this is this is gonna be our
memorabilia
oh yeah oh my god that's such a nice
right we dead ass did not know that was
coming
holy [ __ ] yeah i mean i guess the
champagne as well by the way
yeah and uh i think i think it's time to
get the champagne out before
uh before we talk about the best episode
of cash taste i think we gotta
i wonder i don't know what did you guys
think going into trash takes like what
did you think was going to happen
when you join a podcast i feel like
we've all been on a podcast we all hear
the podcast experience
yeah you know so i i wasn't i wasn't
expecting that exactly but
i wasn't expecting anything different
yeah yeah yeah absolutely i wasn't
expecting anything crazy
i i think the biggest thing is that
obviously none of us expected
for trash taste to be this successful um
because we were i remember when we were
planning this the reason
our studio is so small right now and the
reason we're moving into a new one is
because
we were literally just paying for this
out of pocket and we you know we didn't
know
how successful if this was even going to
make money within the first year like i
remembered a [ __ ] ton of our own money
just to be like we think this can work
i mean i remember like i keep saying it
on episodes but i remember still
you know during the first week or two
where god and i wouldn't be like
it'd be nice if we hit 100k by the end
of the year and now you're approaching
this one
we're almost at a million this is the
end of the year it's just [ __ ] nuts
yeah i mean i can't believe we're just
approaching a [ __ ] million
right that's insane i mean i think i
think it's safe to say that we kind of
like underestimated the potential of a
podcast right i mean i remember
before we even started this podcast we
looked at some of the other competition
out there
right and we were just like okay here's
here's a reasonable estimate of where we
might end up
and it turns out we were just like
[ __ ] five like
ten places too lower than what we
thought we were going to
you know where we thought we were going
to be um i guess before we
unveil the last award um
we'd like to say we'd like to say a few
words if that's cool go ahead
i'll fix this open now before oh i'm
sure crack it crack it open now back it
open now i can open now
pop the share bean baby we're known
we're known for talking [ __ ] a lot but
congratulations
if we could get real for a second joey
just wanted to say something to you okay
like before you know you are one of my
best mates before we start this podcast
and now you're not and like
like especially being on this podcast
every week and just sitting next to you
every week and discussing all that all
of our [ __ ]
it [ __ ] like blows my mind how
similar we are sometimes
like it's it's it's it's [ __ ] insane
that sometimes you say something but
have a thought and i'm just like god
damn it joey
i was gonna say stop being the same
person as me and it's gotten
it's gotten so much i think we've just
like kind of assimilated our like new
answers and everything which you can see
by the amount of clips we have of just
me and joey being insane thinking
like that you know is that just what
happens when you sit next to your best
mate for like both took the red pill in
yeah
fully assimilated yeah yeah i know and
it's like i couldn't be happier to
you know be singing across you and
likewise man one of you uh having like
you as a co-guest
co-host sorry man come on make me
[ __ ] cry
connor my heart my heart connor i know
you were [ __ ] like nervous as [ __ ]
when before starting this podcast
because i know like compared to me and
joey you're you are
like uh you were like you weren't small
but you're like way less established
than you were than us you know this is
and i know you were concerned coming
into this podcast that people would just
be like who the [ __ ] is this guy
who's this guy yeah who's this guy he he
does like [ __ ] black butler
fandubs like who the [ __ ] is this guy no
but um
like i i couldn't be more proud of you
as a mate to see how much you've grown
in the last year
no because like i i think i think out of
everyone you've like grown
the most absolutely the past year of
trash taste and you've definitely like
[ __ ] established yourself
and like you know i you know as a mate i
couldn't be [ __ ] proud of you
come on get ready i'm sure i'm sure
you'd hug too
and everybody clapped and i guess the
last
thanks i want to give is to me lynn
yeah honestly um
we wouldn't be here without meylin
honestly yeah you know me and connor
would not
be here in japan yeah and for sure you
did a [ __ ] like
i know you told the story about how you
just brought us here because it was like
a company competition but
i couldn't be more thankful that you
basically just
created the boys melin yeah do you want
to come on camera no
come on come on you're nicely dressed
come on come on come on man
come on everybody everyone everyone
claps for me everyone give a round of
applause
take a bow melon i have to buy this
outfit
i guess last but last i guess after
melin is
obviously you guys i mean we have just
talked about how we did not expect
the audience that we were going to get
and i certainly didn't expect to have an
audience that was like this dedicated
the subreddit is a lot more popular than
i thought it was going to be
yeah the memes are fantastic the fan
art's fantastic the animation
the animations are fantastic you guys
are just fantastic yeah just how
dedicated you guys are to just us
rambling every week for two hours is
just [ __ ] nuts and i think like
biggest thing more than anything it
really gave me personally
a lot of confidence in just me as a
person
yeah like completely separate from my
personality and like
i don't know that's like that feels
great right it's like oh i'm getting
validated for just
being me and there's no better feeling
than that so yeah
yeah god it feels it sounds like we're
about to like end the podcast yeah
that's my final episode guys it's nice
man i feel like you know you you ready
you already feel like you've made
friends for life but i really do
i'm very lucky to have you know you guys
i'm very very grateful very grateful
i'm really happy as well let's all get
our hands off our dicks and uh get them
all right all right back to [ __ ] talking
back to [ __ ]
with the final category the best episode
of trash taste now obviously we have uh
taken out any other guest episodes
because the guests are on a completely
different calendar this is just the boys
chatting as the boys do honestly we kind
of pick these episodes um so this is
this is
nominations we had nominations for so
many so many episodes so we were just
like
what were the funnest ones for us to
film so this this not
only is like our favorite episodes or
hopefully you know one of our favorite
episodes but these are the episodes that
we want you guys to personally go check
out because these are the ones that we
personally love
yeah but uh yeah let's check out the
nominees all right so
how not to buy anime figures i remember
filming this episode
and this was the first episode that i
filmed and i was like holy [ __ ] i didn't
know being on camera could be that fun
yeah because that was one of the first
like times where you were like fully
fully like outside yeah yeah
right yeah [ __ ] hell and just the
just just the real solo carrying the
performance and just like the
this was the first one where i look back
at and i'm just like man that was that
was a banger episode yeah we
it was one of those things though when
we had all our videos ready to go and
the episode wasn't out
that we i think we were definitely like
i think we've just done like a genius
big brain play
yeah and we made this oh yeah we really
did we were like i
i went live even though i remember i
[ __ ] fell asleep i didn't schedule my
video
that's right so this whole thing had
like three videos on our own channels to
go up at the same time
yeah and i uh i was asleep and i forgot
to schedule it so
yeah both their videos went up i got so
many messages being angry like where's
connor's part
and i panicked and worked up later but i
think yeah like accumulatively between
the episode and our three individual
episodes i think there's a mass like
nine million views 10 million views
which is [ __ ] [ __ ] insane
crazy i really do think that this was
the episode that really
shot trash taste up and put us on the
map basically definitely
it pushed a lot of our audience who
maybe weren't too you know yeah it's
you know you can say check out my new
channel it's like well shout out to
everyone
yeah everyone [ __ ] does all right
yeah to actually give them an incentive
to go check it out and then know maybe
stick around yeah i feel like this was a
difference between our core fan base
being like oh
it's my favorite big youtubers collabing
together to oh they actually make
really funny and good content right
because this is i was really proud of
this episode
and then we got episode 12 which is the
college horror stories which
i personally [ __ ] it's just like a
comfort episode i like this one
i mean to me this has like i in terms of
like density of great stories
this one's a [ __ ] bad truth so many
good stories
so much weird [ __ ] happens in college i
know right i'm still calling for content
and
i remember like going like before going
on this episode i was like maybe i have
like
i have like a clue of what i'm going to
talk about and then they go on it and
then so many
different stories just like flood back
in and i was like oh i forgot that
happened yeah this is
this was the one episode that made me
regret not living in a dorm
i was like [ __ ] you you get such an
insane i was like [ __ ] i wish i lived in
the dorm after hearing your guys anyone
who is deciding to go to college go
go go the life stories
didn't get nominated for more other
categories because he was just so
[ __ ] fun ranting about
being in the anime community which we
are right and just and i feel like
that's why
not many people like think about this or
remember it but like me personally
i remember this episode whenever i want
to rant about anything that's going on
the anime community
oh yeah we have two best episodes back
to back sixteen
and then seventeen oh the japanese food
you've never tried it i
[ __ ] love that this is [ __ ]
fantastic this is where the wine
meme came from as well oh is this this
episode this episode is just iconic
because i i can't believe it took us
like 17
episodes to argue about food and then
this this just like
opened the floodgates and after this
episode we couldn't stop talking about
food
this feels like episode seven yeah i was
like what were we doing for 16 episodes
yeah
like like arguing about food is like an
iconic part of trash taste
and it took 17 episodes for that to
happen it does not feel like a 17
episodes for that to happen
and then of course we have the infamous
episode 25.
i love the title episode oh i love it i
just think there's just like we nailed
everything in there yeah
like we hit all the beats i just like i
we we
that that episode perfectly showed our
personalities
oh yeah
yeah that episode to me like film that
episode was so fun because not only was
like everyone on their a game
but we were just bouncing each other
bouncing off each other so perfectly
like
i'm filming filming this episode and
being like wow we really are drift
compatible
man our horoscopes really do alive yeah
and then we have episode what number is
that we're roasting our horrible anime
taste
we like to say that we're not an anime
podcast yeah but god damn was this fun
to film oh yeah
i think we're a a podcast that just
happens to have three people who want
your [ __ ] tone of anime
occasionally yeah yeah exactly and i
mean to me this was just really fun to
film and just like i
just the mailing moment was just like
the cherry on top
like i i feel like out of everyone this
one ended ended on the biggest bang
just mailing revealing her degeneracy
that just came out of [ __ ] nowhere
um and we revived the three by three
trend as well yeah which i which [ __ ]
nuts
which i guess we'll be doing more of in
future i guess yeah yeah i mean it's
just it's just
a great format to judge a list
bring back three by threes but
we can only choose one i guess the
viewers can choose the viewers can only
choose one
only choose one and this is this one of
all yeah i mean i narrowed it down to
six personally
and uh had you guys choose that top one
i feel like
if you're a i feel like the hentai
episode perfectly sums up trash taste i
feel like and i feel like that could
i will be surprised if it's not that
just because it's so
i mean it's so visceral you see that you
see that title i mean it's like you
react
yeah it's the simplest best right when
it comes to the title it is man it's
like all the other ones you know maybe
you skipped it you didn't skip the
hentai absolutely no no one's killing
everyone i i do all my homies watch this
i do feel like if you want to sell
someone on trash taste people are just
going to show the entire episode
just to be like what what is trash it
does come on really well it's obviously
not the episode you can't show your
friend who is not really into that kind
of stuff
but if they if they're chill with it
show them that episode
by the way i think every episode
deserved it but again
you guys decided on it drum roll please
this is the ultimate winner
so the final award for the trash taste
awards the first annual trash taste
awards
best episode for season one goes to
the hentai episode
yes yes well deserved well-deserved
boyfriend
what a banger well done ass well done
you know it's awesome you're awesome
you're awesome as well
oh my god i'm curious so what was the
percentage what was the final what was
the final percentage
this one with 34.6 percent of the money
okay second place with 19 of the vote
was how to not buy anime figurines
oh
yeah yeah but again like yeah every
episode was an absolute [ __ ] banger
so yeah we wouldn't upload
i mean there's definitely an episode
that i thought were weaker than others
but there's no episode right that i
thought oh we did a bad show yeah yeah i
was like that's not as good
but sometimes you need the mundane to
make you appreciate the really good ones
that come along
you know because we don't do [ __ ] every
week you know yeah exactly in future
there will be episodes that you might
think oh i'm not reading anything i
don't really talk about that interesting
we record every week that's going to
happen yeah but that's that's like real
life right like you know what
mate comes to you every week with like a
banger story right i mean
everyone does i feel like honestly trash
tastes represents
our friendship off camera as well right
because we
sometimes it it it gets weird after
having recorded this for a full year
or you haven't come i have a
conversation with one of these two and i
can't remember if i've
had this conversation on trash taste or
of
yeah but yeah i mean wow i don't even
know what to say man
i don't know i don't know what well i've
i've said everything i'm just i'm just
i'm very grateful for everything you
know some great mates grateful that
the channel is doing so well you know
thank you guys for an entire year
it's been [ __ ] insane and uh man
there's plenty more where that came from
yeah i mean again like we're moving to
the new studio soon so we're hoping
that's going to be like the real end of
season one yeah
that'll be the end of season one yeah
there'll be a bunch of episodes after
this one goes up but the
real yeah the exactly it's the ovs the
real season two start of the news
it's like the spider-man movie after you
know after um was it
after the like avengers movie yeah it's
like this is the real end of phase three
okay okay mom yeah yeah guys hopefully
you enjoyed uh this episode
and uh yeah this is again plenty more
where that came from there's a
i mean i don't think trash tastes could
be done without the beautiful patrons
yeah i mean look at them so many of you
came after the degeneracy that was the
hentai episode
and most of you stuck around
uh yeah if you enjoyed this year of
trash taste and you'd like to continue
supporting us then please go over to our
patreon patreon.com
and uh also follow us on twitter send us
your memes on the subreddit and if you
hate our faces
listen to us on spotify yeah but uh wow
okay i guess final thoughts what do you
guys want out of
next year i want to do more specials
i definitely want to do more special
it's very difficult right now yeah yeah
but i'm hoping that we can
we have we've had one big idea which i'm
not going to say but
we put on the back burner for a while
because yeah obviously yeah i hope we
get a chance to do that hope so yeah
like the biggest thing i'm looking
forward to is one having more specials
because
by far the biggest limiter to having
more specials
has been coping yeah there's just we
haven't been able to get around it and
the fact that we've managed to make
the specials that we did with two of
them being outside was just like the
stars aligning and having this
particular week where
things were open and the country was in
a good enough condition where we could
film them
you know um i'm also looking forward to
having more international guests on yes
yeah yeah hopefully we start getting
them hopefully hopefully and i'm i'm
also just looking forward to like more
kind of casual content as well that we
can hopefully start you know putting up
on
after dark and stuff like that more
streams hopefully yeah i mean we
haven't been uploading much to after
dark because we kind of want to get
everything set up in the new studio
and get everything set up there so that
it's way easier to make after the dark
content
also the new studio just looks way
better right now we are extremely
cramped in here
yeah uh-huh just wait just wait till you
see season two
yeah season two is gonna be gonna be
good it's gonna be good but uh anyways
guys that's that's probably gonna do it
yeah for this uh thank you for joining
us on the first annual trash test
award-winner
and uh i hope you enjoyed it yeah
hopefully you guys enjoyed it please
uh look forward to more content coming
out soon we're this this is just the
beginning
and we're gonna keep going on from here
yep all right but hopefully you guys
enjoyed it
and i don't have anything else to say
yeah i mean i don't know man it's just
uh
it's over yeah
that's it man it's sad you know i mean i
feel like it's uh it's been a sweet you
know it's been a good year but it's like
okay next year now yeah
or enjoy the ova episodes that are going
to come out afterwards
no no no okay having already filmed some
of them
there are some banger episodes going out
the ovals are just as good
honestly honestly if you think if you
think trash tastes peaked you're wrong
yeah honestly some of the ovas are just
i mean they're not they're not ovas
they're just they're just they're just
episodes they're just
banger episodes before we get to our new
um new place yeah thank you for the year
we'll see you next week
all right every week we'll see you every
[ __ ] week we can't get rid of us see
you next week
see you later guys
[Music]
you